a from single-use plastics to um to
refillable mul you know refillable
plastic bottles
i think has been has been good for the
environment and and also encourages
students and
anybody that's uh carrying around a
refillable water bottle to uh to remain
hydrated during the day and that is uh
that is as the doctor as dr sherman
pointed out good for uh for people's
health overall
one of the additional things we did in
in hopkinton to make sure that all
students had access was uh was
in conjunction with rolling out the
hydration stations uh we did a campaign
uh to uh to provide all of our students
with uh with um with hopkinton water
bottles and i have one one of them with
me today this was back in the
2013-2014 school year so it was probably
i got this from my son's room so uh so i
did empty it out and i'm sure that this
is full of clean uh filtered
uh water so uh so if there are any
questions um i'd be happy to to take
them uh and um and thank you very much
for for um uh hopefully some getting
your support for this bill thanks thank
you very much representative luna are
there any questions representative
porter
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative this is just my ignorance
at the water bottle filling stations is
it possible to get a drink of water if
you don't have a bottle to fill
so that's a that's a great question and
and i actually asked um um
rebecca wilson that that question she
was she was with the hopkins school
district at the time and i was trying to
remember that um i think there are some
models that uh that that do both um a a
bubbler as well as a as a filling
station i think in hopkinton we did not
replace bubblers with with filling
stations we put the filling stations
either near or uh
or in an area in areas where where um
where clearly there would be demand for
uh for for hydration stations so so we
we supplemented the avail the
availability of bubbler water with with
hydration stations
further questions
yes representative cornell
thank you and this is thank you for
taking my question it's more of a
comment after 36 years in a middle
school i agree that bubblers are really
gross
and and i think this is a wonderful idea
so thank you very much for that question
because i feel exactly the the same way
about the the bubbler down at the top of
the hallway here and uh and um the chair
had uh had had advised me rather than
filling um my water bottle there uh to
go into the um the the back side of the
uh the finance uh room where they
filtered water uh system in there so
thank you very much i'm glad glad you
took my advice i did
um i i do have a question for you in the
bill it talks about um
if you're going to have new construction
or a substantial renovation and i know
within the school building aid program
we have a definition of what renovation
is it's a certain percentage of the to
replace the whole thing right um
is there is that the definition that
we're going to be using in this bill uh
to define what is a substantial
innovation is it just re replacing the
boiler system or the heating system
yeah i think it would probably have to
be beyond that but it would be subject
to rule making under uh 541a as as as as
spelled out on line four
on uh section one of the bill so the
department would would be doing rule
making on that and i would i would
imagine they'd probably replicate the um
the definition from the um the approved
uh building projects um definition of
substantial but but this does also
extend to approved building projects too
under um under 198.
is it 198.15 and uh
so any project that's going to be uh be
applying for um for uh building aid
would also have to incorporate um
hydration stations into the body i
noticed that uh senator sherman just
walked in the room um
i've stolen his son sherman
do you want to come up and sit beside
representative he's introducing your
bill
thank you so much
thank you mr chair for the record tom
sherman district 24 senate uh 11 towns
on the seacoast and i'm sure he did a
spectacular job
uh i just came over from i i had two
bills at nine o'clock so i apologize uh
not being able to be
two places at once uh
i only if you have questions i don't
well i do have one for you and i have
one for
for dave but uh
when you
brought this forward did you look to get
a fiscal analysis and what kind of costs
are we looking at in terms of
of uh
putting this uh program into effect in
the schools
uh thank you for the question there is a
fiscal note and of course it's
indeterminable so i i saw
the goal of this though as as you know
we always try to avoid
anything that tells municipalities
what to do what not to do um
that will result
in a significant increase in cost to
them
so the goal here was exactly that and
that's why we limited it to
new construction and substantial
construction i think the heart
association will be able to talk about
the relative cost but
the cost savings are that you don't need
as many of these systems as you need
bubblers
and then long-term of course the cost
savings are in health because these are
filtering devices and
that means that the water we do have
problems with contaminants in our water
systems and
in the schools and this filters those
out
you know you can filter out arsenic and
lead with a filter pitcher so it's not
like some of the more
uh difficult to filter out contaminants
these are relatively easy and in the
developing child
lead and arsenic are two of them biggest
neurotoxins
around that's why we're so worried about
them so
it's sort of a win-win it's it's if it's
done appropriately it's not going to be
a significant cost increase over
bubblers
and then long-term to the state to the
families to the children it's a huge
cost saver because the
you know we've seen from other places
the the impact and cost of
having high lead levels or elevated lead
levels and asbestos is just in new
hampshire it's we're the granite state
so we're the asbestos state so it's it's
it's something that's there and
that will all be filtered out which is
being on the drinking water groundwater
trust fund commission with senator morse
um
this is a huge passion of mine is to
make sure the water is clean yes i i and
just a follow-up
we did pass the lead uh bill here great
which is great and so with that are
there further questions from the
thank you mr chair thank you senator and
representative for both being here um
i i guess that um this would require
a new policy to be developed
by the local school board you know
looking at
bottom of page one and over on to page
two
and that that policy may include a
i was just wondering um with
roman 4 c on the
topic page 2
have you heard of or experienced
possibly um any instances where uh the
water bottles were not exclusively
filled with water
great question and of course that you
know
there's already disciplinary issues with
bubblers you you know the frequent flyer
that child who
is always having to go get a drink of
water um
and so in a way this will
be beneficial to that our kids are
completely used to this at our ski areas
most of them have these water bottle
filling stations
and i don't think they're putting
substances in those per se
that would
need to be borne out over time but what
the bill does and and this was thanks to
senator hennessey she put
some of this in there to give
the schools the ability to regulate
where bottles could go
and
and so i really appreciate she made the
bill much better by
putting in that ability for the schools
thank you very much uh representative
lakers
yes thank you um
i guess i'm picturing the
how this all works
and so i'm wondering in um
when it's talking about
you know extensive
what do they say uh substantial
renovations
i'm wondering a school that's putting on
an addition
does that
that's a pretty substantial renovation
but it has nothing to do with the major
body of the school
and so would
that apply to them
and then the other part of that question
is
are these pretty easy to hook up to like
if there is a
already a water fountain right where
there's plumbing run to it is this
something
that's pretty easy i'm just thinking of
all our old schools
and how difficult plumbing is and is
this going to be something that's pretty
easy to then
tap off of that plumbing that's there to
install
yeah that's a great question
i'm just a gastroenterologist so i deal
with human plumbing and not that type of
plumbing
the retrofit you already see that
happening all over the place they're
retrofitting in in ski areas like cannon
mountain and others
where the plumbing is
older than me and um
so i don't think a retrofit is a big
issue okay but but what you do bring up
is there is already a requirement for
access to water drinking water in new
large editions
and this actually requires less of these
facilities than bubblers
so and i think the heart association
will be able to speak to that
but that's one of the efficiencies that
you're getting
from doing this is that you
you don't need as many um as you do the
others
further reps and hops and i saw you have
your hand up you have a follow-up well i
did have a follow-up sorry that's to
thank you for taking my question uh uh
senator sherman i was just wondering
what kind of filter do they use is this
a carbon filter does it need to be
replaced i don't see any information
right there there is a line in here they
they typically are carbon filters you
know resin filters are the ones that you
would use for pfas and that gets into
a whole different level that's just not
that's not really
reasonable in this setting
but the carbon filters will get most of
what i think it's line 14 on the first
page
water bottle filling stations installed
in public schools under this section
shall be regularly cleaned
and then section 2 be maintained to
ensure they function properly including
replacing filters
and
you know the carbon filters aren't
really a big deal disposal they go into
lined landfills because they do carry
all those lovely contaminants that we're
keeping out of our children's
gi tracts but um
but
they're you know many of us have i have
carbon filter at home so you know many
of us have those
thank you
uh
i see uh senator ward in here you didn't
feel it are you wanting to talk are you
just accompanying the other senator to
the room we don't go anywhere without
oh you're here for the next one okay
great any further questions
a quick one because i know the senators
have to get out i know just real quick
is there anything to deal with bathroom
breaks because i know numerous students
decide not to drink because they don't
have time to go to the bathroom
and if we are encouraging drinking which
we should it's unhealthy not to drink
and not to go to the bathroom
are we addressing that in any way
not really although you know good
hydration means you have to go to the
bathroom so as we all know um but
you know that would be up to the teacher
and the child and working out those
relationships
what it would mean is less drinking
water i mean drinking fountain breaks
because they would have their own supply
with them
thank you thank you very much senator
and representative luno appreciate it
okay uh nancy vaughn from the american
heart association
for information for the committee here
we also have diana fenton here from the
department for technical questions if we
good morning um for the record um i am
nancy vaughn director of government
relations for the american heart
association
i really don't i have um comments but
they've all been covered already um so i
think what i will mainly say is you know
this is a a priority of the american
heart association is to ensure children
are properly hydrated
interests and
properly hydrated children are also
better prepared for learning
and all of this is is covered within my
written testimony as well
so this is an appropriate place for this
policy to to reside
and we strongly encourage you to pass
this on but if you do have any questions
i'm very happy to take those on
just one of the questions that was
mentioned
with the american heart association
perhaps providing the answer
when we looked to writing this bill
did look at what the current language is
within department of education for
construction and substantial renovation
was the term that they use and there is
i believe a financial
you know
threshold that that begins that but
these are definitely devices that can be
added to current plumbing
for the renovation type areas there are
so many different models a water bottle
filling station some can be incorporated
in existing water fountains some of them
come with their own water fountains as
well as the filling station but
um yeah so any other questions that you
have because both the center and the
representative did a great job
introducing this bill thank you very
much nancy are there any questions for
the heart association
now cnn thank you very much thank you
very much
uh just quickly are there any questions
from the department technical support
here yes representative tanner
uh colonel are you willing to come on up
good morning i hate to
pass a time
you know when i could ask you a question
i would miss that as well
my question is about the fiscal note on
the back of the of the of this bill
that um although it's indeterminable i
would assume from lba
this is from the department of education
who said that these
uh water filling stations approximately
a thousand dollars
uh and regular drinking fountains range
between four and five hundred dollars um
i'm wondering if that's just a
guesstimate or whether there was actual
research done on that
so thank you for the question for the
record my name is dianna fenton i'm an
attorney with the department of
education and all this discussion about
water and water bottle filling stations
i felt very guilty drinking my diet
pepsi in the back of the room so i need
to self self assess here um
so
as your question this fiscal note was
done i believe by amy clark uh who this
committee is well aware of um
i can't speak directly for her but my
experience with amy clark is she does
not guesstimate
she is an engineer she's very precise
and i have no doubt that she looked up
the average cost of this i know that i
approve this fiscal note as is our
process but i did not oversee and
micromanage amy's work but i would uh
feel confident telling you that these
are pretty accurate prices yeah it just
seems a little high um maybe it's
taking into consideration
new rather than retrofitting but i would
blame it on the supply chain issues okay
everything's gone up
um the department just has one minor uh
point to address to this committee as it
pertains to senate bill 233 and that is
the concern of um this does contain
rulemaking pursuant to 541a and the
effective date says this act shall take
effect 60 days after passage
the department would ask this committee
committee to recognize that rulemaking
simply takes time we would ask for 90
days or maybe even 180 days recognizing
that there are significant number of
bills coming out that require rulemaking
and so we have to be cognizant of our
ability to enter into that rulemaking
process within that required time frame
so that would be the department's um
i have one further request from you um
when you get back and talk with amy
clarke i'm curious to know when we wrote
the school building aid
language in statute
and we put down a definition for what a
renovation project is a substantial
renovation as a certain percentage of
replacing the building as new
i'd like to find out from her
if this is the proper language a
substantial renovation i don't want to
get confused with what we have in school
building aid that could be a sizeable
hunk of money that you have to do rather
than just replacing for example your
electrical systems or your hvac sure i
will have amy contact you and you can
have a further discussion on that that's
a very valid point thank you thank you
further questions of the department yes
representative waltz
thank you here's my question do you
really need rule making or should we
i mean it seems sort of general i'm not
sure that there's a specific need for
you know ultimately that's this
committee's decision to make but i think
given what it relates to which is
construction projects it it
i think it's well advised to have rule
making and i don't think it has to be a
lengthy rule making
thank you but representative walsh has a
point when we did the embedded
mathematics course in the fourth grade
we wrote language in the bill so you
wouldn't have to put rule making in
place
certainly way you can do it so there's a
number of ways of doing it and you can
narrowly tailor what the rule making is
to pertain to as well yes so thank you
further questions the department thank
you very much i have no other pink cards
unless there's somebody out in the
audience who wants to speak on this
particular bill
not seeing any we'll close this hearing
and get ready to go into the next one
which is sb 234
this is hearing on requiring student
identification cards to include the
national suicide prevention
lifeline
that's another 233 right there
representative ward is yeah wow you're
there i'm here good morning ruth good
morning
uh for the record uh first good morning
mr chair and members of the committee
for the record i am ruth ward
senator for the 8th district
and i'm here to introduce
senate bill 234
this bill requires
student identification cards for public
schools and institutions of higher
education
to include the telephone number for the
national suicide prevention lifeline
the bill was amended in the committee
because we had a whole mess of numbers
listed but we decided it would be very
cumbersome and the best thing was just
to have the national
this bill does not require schools to
all of a sudden
print id cards these are for the schools
who already have student id cards to put
it
this number on that cards will be easy
to get to in case a child is student
is in trouble and really needs some
quick help
it's fairly straightforward it came out
of a resident who whose son had
committed suicide
and
really felt that this will be a big help
for the students
and i'm very pleased to see that this
morning i received a letter which i
think you all have from governor sununu
talking about the number of students who
commit suicide and what age group is
most vulnerable so i'm very pleased to
be able to produce this
bill for your consideration
so the senate education committee is
asked for your approval of this bill
and with the amendment which was to cut
out all the other numbers except one the
and again on the letter from governor
sununu talks about
the mental health problems with our
youth and what we can do and i think
this is a small
effort in that way of keeping our youth
safe
i should also mention to you that the
mother of this young man
had requested if possible to have the
bill named in his name and i will leave
that up to you
thank you very much
and uh one question answer any questions
yes one question for you in in
developing this did you work with either
tom cronin or others over at the the
university system new hampshire
coordinate this i because it addresses
suicide prevention higher education
which is our two and four year system
was there
communication with them
that are they in support do you know
i did not
personally contact any one of them this
is an issue that has been talked about
so many times that uh
oh she did not
okay it came out of the the request came
out of the governor's office because she
this particular woman had reached out to
the governor's office thank you thank
you very much other questions for the
senator yes representatives
thank you
um i just have a question
on li on section four
in uh the first part
it says the national suicide prevention
lifeline
shall be labeled on student
identification cards as
the mental health support line
and i'm just wondering why you did that
instead of leaving it labeled as the
national
line 14 the national suicide prevention
lifeline shall be labeled on student
identification cards as the mental
health support line yeah why did you
if you have
mental health problems and you're
thinking about suicide i think that's
probably
what a child might reach for mental
health thinking that they're in crisis
they need some help versus if they see
the national suicide they may not be
there yet but i think the mental health
has a
it's a little easier to take than the
suicide prevention line but the suicide
prevention people
yes i'm sorry the suicide prevention
people would then be able to deal with
whoever
even if they're not there yet they have
all of the abilities to do that
that
you call that line they will answer and
they will deal with the issue
thank you very much
further questions for the senator yes
represent luna thank you very much mr
chair thank you very much senator for
taking uh taking my question um does uh
does any aspect of of this bill prohibit
a um
a public school a charter school or
public or private institute of higher
learning to um
to put other
phone numbers on
on their student identification cards
like
if you're in an emergency
call 911 or
or
something like that
thank you for your question
the reason we did not put all the other
names and all the other numbers on is
because i don't know how big the id card
is but how many numbers can you put on
it and which ones are the most important
follow-up yes yeah so so um so i'm i'm
taking from that that that this wouldn't
prohibit
um any of these institutions from from
placing other helpful numbers yes thank
you it would not
represent boom
thank you mr chairman and thank you
senator technic uh question
back to
a follow-up on representative lakers's
thing
wouldn't it be better for the students
because if i'm contemplating suicide in
sixth grade
i might
correlate that to
mental health
so i would think wouldn't it be better
maybe say meant or
suicide
prevention
i mean putting that putting one with the
other might not correlate to
a child's mind that they mean the same
thing
well as you probably know it's hard to
figure out what is the best way to doing
it
kids react to different things
and if you can see
any other way of putting whatever
information is the most important on a
card i would say go for it
when it's
you know do you decide to have the
national
mental health line suicide line
emergency line and there are so many
things that could be put on the card the
question is how much can you put on a
card so you can actually see it and it
makes sense
well well
quick yeah good for i mean just the
point is
if i'm i'm a
ninth grader or something and i just
break up with my girlfriend then i might
think suicide because of that which most
kids do
that's not to me that's not mental
health that's i broke up with my
girlfriend so don't you think maybe
adding in
all
the suicide hotline
we're going to have uh the national
alliance for mental health association
coming up here and speaking in in a few
moments here so
maybe we can have these questions
regarding mental health versus the
the other definition addressed to them
when they come up any further questions
for the senator
thank you very much ruth thank you
i'd like to invite up michelle watson
good morning chairman and committee
members my name is michelle watson i am
here
representing the national alliance on
mental illness
for holly stevens who is our director of
public policy she's in another committee
hearing this morning
so i passed out to you our testimony
which i'll read to you
thank you for the opportunity to testify
today
my name is michelle watson not holly
stevens
and
part of what i do at nami new hampshire
is i am the new hampshire family network
coordinator and part of my job is doing
connect suicide prevention training out
in the community
nami new hampshire is a non-pro
non-profit nonpartisan grassroots
organization whose mission is to improve
the lives of all people impacted by
mental illness and suicide through
support education and advocacy on behalf
of nominee new hampshire i'm here today
to speak in favor of sb 234 requiring
student identification cards to include
the national suicide prevention lifeline
over the past decade already high
suicide rates have been rising in the
united states and in new hampshire
on your on the letter you'll see a chart
that details the leading causes of death
in the u.s this chart is the product of
the national center for injury
prevention and control at the centers
for disease control and prevention
it shows that the leading second leading
cause of death for 10 to 24 year olds is
suicide this is the exact age range that
this legislation is targeting
additionally according to health affairs
between 2007 and 2018
suicide increased 57.4 percent
in 10 to 24 year olds in one survey of
high school students one in three youth
reported persistent feelings of sadness
or hopelessness and one in five had
seriously considered suicide
more precisely results from the 2019
youth behavioral risk factor
surveillance system show that 18.8
percent
of high school students seriously
considered attempting suicide and 8.9
percent uh
considered it an 8.9 percent attempted
suicide
sb 234 offers a simple solution that has
the potential to save lives
suicide phone lines provide timely and
constant access to a resource that
provides support and comfort to those
who are actively suicidal
printing this number on the back of a
student id is a great way to assure that
this age group has access to this very
important resource for these reasons
nami new hampshire urges the committee
to vote to recommend ought to pass for
sb 234
thank you very much
and uh any questions for the committee
could you
we were discussing earlier what
definition we should
use within this legislation mental
health line and helpline or or
our
suicide prevention line uh you're
professional in the field and work in
this domain
could you give us any advice or comments
um well i'm not technically a
professional and i work with families
through my lived experience
um
and
what the research shows is that
the kids just need access to a number
um and as the senator said it really
either number can be on there
the kid
the students that i've been working with
in the past year a couple of years we've
had a contest around mental health they
get it more than we do
and so i think having either number on
there would be helpful
the other thing that was mentioned was
you know perhaps breaking up with your
boyfriend or your girlfriend your
significant other
the data shows that there's never one
single cause to suicide
so while
students may feel hopeless and very sad
there's a lot more behind it to those
that actively get to that part but we do
know as was mentioned that this number
really addresses
in crisis they don't have to be to the
to the level of um feeling that they're
going to harm themselves at that
particular moment but they do have the
ability to
reach out and help
help and talk with them
the other thing is that as we move
forward to having the national 988
number
that is going to be for anybody that's
in a mental health or substance misuse
crisis
thank you questions from the committee
yes representative yeah thank you mr
chair thanks for taking the question i'm
just curious
has this been done in any other state
and how much of an impact did it have
i'm sorry i don't have the answer to
that
but we do know that having access to the
further questions representative cornell
thank you thank you for taking my
question
do you know if the 988 number after
speaking with whoever calls will make a
help them make a referral to some place
local to talk to or yes so in new
hampshire when you call this national
suicide prevention lifeline or when you
call 988 you will be directed to new
hampshire
and then they will work on making sure
it gets to that area and as we do
when they call that the goal is to help
them at that time hopefully
we don't need to call 9-1-1 but it's
it's all to de-escalate at that moment
you're welcome thank you
further questions
thank you very much for coming today
thank you very much i'd like to invite
up martha dickey
representing herself
good morning chairman ladd and members
of the education committee
my name is martha dickey and i'd like to
thank you for allowing me to speak today
in favor of senate bill 234 relative
requiring student identification cards
to include the national suicide
prevention lifeline and i'm going to go
off script or some number that will help
people if they are in crisis on
september 14 2017 we lost our son jason
to suicide a day that will haunt us for
the rest of our lives jason was just 19
at the time of his death
he loved his friends and family and made
everyone around him happy he will always
be loved and missed
according to the cdc between 2007 and
2018 the national suicide rate among
young people aged 10 to 24 increased 57
percent well it's hard to pinpoint why
the rate has gone up we know everybody
has their challenges and that has become
even more obvious during this pandemic
as teen suicide rates continue to rise
there are other states that are trying
to make it easier for students to reach
out for help by putting it right in the
palm of their hand when i started to
read about this i knew that i had to
bring the concept forth here in new
hampshire and i am honored to speak here
today on behalf of and in favor of this
bill and to thank senator ward for the
work that she's done to bring it this
far
newly passed laws in south carolina
illinois and arizona are putting the
national suicide prevention lifeline
number on student id cards california
has required the lifeline to be on id
cards since 2019 and several other
states currently have similar bills
before them as well
i believe that passing a similar bill in
new hampshire would be life-saving
showing this level of support to
students who may feel vulnerable or
unsupported is important and i believe
that it will change their lives
even though jason was already graduated
from high school he kept this id card in
his wallet and it was with him that
morning when he took his life i can't
help but wonder if this id had a number
that he could have reached out to
perhaps he would have called it that
morning and saved himself through that
resource
these resources must be made readily
available it is our duty as parents
educators professionals and lawmakers to
help prevent teen suicide to know that a
teen reaches out and says help me that's
a sign of courage and tremendous
strength to infuse hope that there is
someone on the other end of a telephone
whether they call or text might give
them a chance to know that they're only
a call away from talking to a trained
expert no matter what a person is going
through there is always hope
i've said before that even if one life
is saved you've all done your part to
help i appreciate your thoughtfulness
regarding the bill before you and
sincerely hope that it passes and i do
respectfully ask that we consider naming
it after my son jason dickey thank you
for your service to the state of new
hampshire and for your time today
thank you very much martha are there
questions
from the committee yes representatives
just following up on the same question i
noticed you nodding your head and
shaking your head when we were
discussing that so it seemed like you
had an opinion
as to which nay i mean the number will
be the same but as to how we label it
right exactly and i know that that had
gone back and forth thank you i was
agreeing and not not agreeing to some
things um i think that a number to your
point that they can look at the back of
that card i noticed that jason's is
blank he had typed something that says
peace of mind comes piece by piece so to
me that indicates that the kids look at
the back of their ids
i think a number that could connect them
and i do agree that the 988 number down
the road when that's live would probably
be the best bet and then however it's
labeled whether it's mental health
suicide i think it's all going to tie
back and potentially be life-saving
so thank you thank you
thank you very much further questions
from the committee thank you again
martha thank you all
devon is from the new hampshire women's
foundation
good morning good morning chairman
members of the committee my name is
devin quinn and i'm here on behalf of
the new hampshire women's foundation
invests in equality and opportunity for
the women and girls of new hampshire
through research advocacy education and
grant making
in addition to
the testimony that you've heard and
we'll hear
we also wanted to point out how
important and life-saving this bill
would be for girls in particular
we put out a report in the fall called
the status of girls in new hampshire and
we saw
as you can see
in the
kj sent around
as you can see
the stats for girls mental health are
particularly alarming
girls
have a higher rate of depression than
boys
they have a higher rate than boys for
considering suicide
and indeed have a
higher rate of making a plan
to attempt suicide um so
oh that those numbers are
exaggerated and increased by certain
groups of girls of color and by certain
regions on the second page you'll see
which regions are most impacted
so we wanted to make sure
that that was part of the discussion as
well as how impactful this would be on
girls lives as well
thank you are there questions from the
committee
not seeing any thank you very much
and the last card i have
is ted stockaliskey
i don't know if i pronounced her right
good morning everyone um i served in the
marine corps and it's always is hard to
do this um so i greatly appreciate you
um
giving me the opportunity to speak on
behalf of supporting
senate bill 234
first of all i'm a suicide survivor
i'm a parent i have a daughter who's a
freshman at the university of new
hampshire and hopefully actually glad i
came i'd always support something like
this but also i have a lot of answers to
the questions that you're seeking that
you've asked
so my background is
i attempted suicide back in 1986 as a
junior at salem high school
some of you may know my story because
two years ago i testified for the on
behalf of the return to learn concussion
bill which i said using my experience a
child that is separated from their peers
is a um is a recipe for suicide it just
adds to increasing suicide i was a
multi-sport athlete at multiple
concussions uh it got to the point where
i couldn't do my schoolwork and back
then it was live your life in a at home
in a dark room away from your peers um
i testified that it
that bill would help
students get support by being in the
classroom being with their peers and it
was in line with the governor's governor
sununu's suicide prevention plans that
that he's outlined over the years
right after that covet hit the covet
lockdowns um suicide rates have gone up
and i believe primarily because these
students are separated from this
from the other students they're teachers
as my daughter said to me uh last month
when unh took the mask mandates away she
said dad i haven't seen a teacher one of
any of my teachers faces in three years
since i was a junior in high school
it's really impactful
i went on to serve in the marine corps
well even before that i was one of the
first trained peer outreach counselors
back in 1986. so that program has been
going on for 36 years and what did it
teach us
i'm sorry my phone um what it taught us
was that how students can reach out for
help out in the community first
responders your clergy what have you and
a lot of what's based around suicide is
um
who you who do you reach out to it's
communication problem and you feel
whether you're a student or whether
you're uh a combat veteran there's a lot
of stigmas around reaching out to people
so i served in the marine corps and for
the past 17 years i've been a veterans
outreach specialist at the at the va
here in new england and national myself
and others that are here like nami and
so forth we are all local lifelines but
every single month for 17 years i've
referred
veterans combat veterans and others
adults and parents of children who have
mental health problems and suicidal to
the national suicide prevention hotline
whether it's in the middle of the night
one of our lifelines gets a phone call
and i'm just an independent guy i've
worked for the brain injury association
of new hampshire i've served on the new
hampshire brain and spinal cord injury
advisory council and other boards and
committees um but still
there's only so much we can do and you
leave it to this
to the specialists on the other end of
that lifeline and then people will come
back to me and say gee you helped you
saved my life well i assisted in that
because it was the professionals at the
other end of that lifeline that helped
de-escalate the situation to calm
somebody down to start to think a little
bit rational and then to
tailor it back to resources here in new
hampshire to help
um
to help get them the right mental health
treatments and whatever they need
medical treatments and so forth um
so that's why i'm here i hold dearly
this to me this has been my life every
part of my life from um
with peer outreach whether i'm a child
or now as an adult and a veteran or
whatnot it's it's what i do
um
i called my daughter this morning at the
university of new hampshire and i asked
her i said sam
look on the back of your id card does it
mention does it have the suicide
prevention hotline number immediately
without even looking at it she goes dad
not only does it have the number but it
also has a text you can text in my
daughter is a communication science
disorder
student there she's going to be a speech
therapy again it comes back to
communication and who's there to help so
i'm very proud of my daughter she sent
me a copy of her id card and to answer
the questions
it's actually i'm so proud of unh and
whoever did this and i'm very proud of
the and thankful for the family to come
forward to bring this i'm like oh my god
why don't we think about this sooner
i can share with anybody i didn't
photocopy it she sent me in a text
in the biggest boldest letters it says
emergencies 9-1-1 there's another
program called sharp it's a 603 number
it says report bias discrimination and
harassment and down at the bottom it
says national suicide prevention hotline
with a text number or the 1 800 number
so you know somebody there at university
of new hampshire has just you know
they're doing it and so i see that
written in the bottom of the bill but
maybe there are other schools i haven't
called timberlane uh my local high
school or whoever but i think this is a
fantastic thing to do
one more thing
is i'm a veteran if any of you are
veterans and you have a va health card
it says right on the back and now i wish
it was bigger because as we get older
our vision gets worse um veterans crisis
line every month i refer veterans to
call this phone number
and what i've heard from feedback is
that a lot of times they actually it's
connected with the national hotline the
national suicide prevention hotline so
the question just to answer that i think
it should say national suicide
prevention hotline
i look back as if i was a kid and i had
a school id card i couldn't talk to
because of stigma i couldn't talk to my
coaches i couldn't talk to my friends or
my family they didn't know what was
going on or i didn't want to burden them
this takes the burden away because
you're talking to a trained professional
whether you're an eighth grader or a
senior at the university of new
hampshire or a combat veteran you're
talking to somebody who is distant from
because maybe somebody in the situation
that you're in
they're part of the reason of the
multiple issues of why you're you're
contemplating harming yourself
so again my name is today and say my
name is ted stachelski i'm from plaistow
new hampshire i grew up in salem new
hampshire
and i greatly support
and thank the people who brought this
bill forward senate bill 234.
any questions i greatly answer them
thank you very much ted and for sharing
all this real good information to us
here
us army to maureen thank you very much
thank you sir
um are there questions from the
committee yes represent tanner
uh thank you for taking my question and
also
thank you so much for coming and talking
uh i noticed you said text number as
well and i'm wondering with the young
people today if maybe we should have an
amendment to this bill to include a text
number
i think that would be great i heard the
other number that was mentioned um
i actually know veterans who actually
text as well so
i'm all for it whatever number's there
big and bold somebody had mentioned the
size of an id card there's plenty of
room on the back because the stuff that
is really that needs to be small
unh can do it maybe i can get a copy of
that in a different way to share with
the committee or whatnot but there is
plenty of room on the back of an id card
to put whatever you need for these um
anybody in crisis to to reach out
so
thank you very much shannon you're in
the crowd um would you please contact
tom cronin over there at the university
system and i also like to know what
you're doing at the community college
uh further
questions yes representative nelson and
then representative mitchfield thank you
mr chairman and thank you for taking my
question
any thought for bilingual students that
may speak only spanish or something how
do they address that maybe i should ask
i've been on the national suicide
hotline uh there's a website and maybe
that's another thing they could put down
is the web page as well again how much
room do you have at that point too but
they do have people who speak different
languages when you call the hotline just
like if you're a veteran you call they
can ask you are you a veteran and you
can
it gets tailored down to who you need to
speak to and again who you can who can
communicate with you best during this
crisis so
um
thank you thank you uh represent
litchfield
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
one thing that i've struggled with
throughout this conversation today was
the verbiage of
suicide versus mental health i agree
with the need for this
but i i continue to go through my mind
and think that if 11 year olds are going
to be carrying the surrounded 12 year
olds i have young children i don't know
that i want them to have the word
suicide that seed planted continually in
their brain but yet
i don't disagree with having the number
on there you said something interesting
where you mentioned the word in crisis
how do you feel about that
yeah i was thank you for the question um
i was looking at this as well i mean
that's a good point veterans crisis line
that you know i pondered that
um this morning as i looked at you know
i was looking at all these id cards i'm
like wow
why didn't they use
national suicide prevention hotline or
or use the word suicide um
because with veterans that's a
that's a tough
subject and i understand where you're
coming from that's
that's a good point um
and again the veterans crisis line
actually routes you to
the national suicide prevention hotline
and then services back here so
i guess i'd leave that up with the
educators and the experts as far as
which word to use but as far as unh
university students big bold letters
national suicide prevention hotline
thank you
thank you very much ted uh further
questions from the committee thank you
very much for coming today appreciate it
i don't have any other red cards or pink
cards up here for this bill uh not
seeing anybody else in the audience i
will close that wants to speak i will
and we will go now into sb 236 this is
establishing a committee to study new
hampshire teacher shortages and
you very much for coming today senator
khan
thank you representative land
i know we're all busy i'll uh hopefully
the
matter of uh teacher shortages and
shortage areas is something that we've
been documenting for many years in the
state it's something that mr steve
appleby of the department of education
who's uh present and able to
to answer probably other questions that
about teacher shortage areas
he
keeps track of that with the department
as well as all licensure certification
matters
but
of the things that are known about new
hampshire's
shortage areas we have
54 endorsements that the
offers
and
of those 54 in 2018
46 of them were deemed to be critical
shortage areas so these would be
areas that are education specialists
administrators counselors teachers
uh
paraprofessionals and
substitutes not included in those
categories
in 2019 of the 54 endorsement areas 50
were deemed to be critical shortage
areas and in
of the 54
endorsements
the department uh took a hiatus in 2021
and
is in the process of trying to collect
but at any rate these
these three years are pretty good data
pretty consistent data
uh
and i i think
at least my awareness there's not much
difference in my uh senate district
that would give me reason to to to doubt
that this has gotten much
better by the way i should have
introduced myself with the outset of
this
representative lad uh i am j khan i am
from keene uh
state senator and uh represent
uh 15 of the 23 towns in cheshire county
um
so that's the that's the the basis for
bringing forward this bill uh to
establish a study committee
of the legislature
uh to
look at
how the state might address its teacher
shortage
and
both in the recruitment and retention
study
the study would
i have a 14-month life span to it
assuming that it convened in september
and concluded its work by november of
just to give a sense of how important
the senate thinks this is
uh
there are two senators
that survived the
gauntlet in the senate
named to this committee along with three
members of the house
we are not alone
in this kind of study
i
just hit my map around 2015.
that other states were looking at their
critical shortages in teacher education
i noticed that first in the western
states
i consulted with the education
commission of the states
in filing this bill
at that point by november of 2021 20
states had completed studies
and since that time they've done an
updated bulletin and there are more
states getting into this so
it is something that we don't need to
create out of whole cloth
there are lots of ideas that other
states have come up with
our task i think in new hampshire would
be and what best fits our state our
budget situation
uh and the needs of school districts
uh to fill the critical shortage areas
that we have in our state and provide
recommendations back to the legislature
that we could hopefully act upon in a
biennial budget year
and provide some
ideas
for
recruitment
retention uh to ease this shortage
that's all that i've got in my way of
presentation and be glad to
answer any questions committee members
have thank you very much senator um we
have some questions i got a first uh
something to ask you
um
the other day when i was at a meeting in
keene
i'm trying to get back home trying to
get to vermont
i ended up in brattleboro
uh going south uh can you do something
about posting the signs down there how
to get back up to haverhill from
from keene from the college
that that that's off topic i know it
senator i just wonder if i have to call
vermont transportation or well all the
signs say vermont and i knew i had to
get there to the interstate highway
let's get to some questions here
representative porter and then
representative tanner
thank you uh mr chair all you had to do
was go north you try doing that in keene
okay
thank you every day senator for taking
taking my question this is just a minor
detail sometimes when we set up these
committees um it's specified in the
statute that uh so many members of the
majority party so many members of the
minority party are part of the of the
committee this does not do that and i'm
wondering if
that matters to you or
if that's something we
you raise a very good point the idea of
having two from the senate was that
hopefully it would have
one member of each party i don't think
it's a partisan issue and
hopefully
we'd have
uh one from each party that was the
sometimes you're lucky just to get one
senator
uh representative uh tanner you had your
hand up
yes it was a
and thank you senator khan um it was
basically the same question that that
the bill is bipartisan and it seems like
the committee should be bipartisan but
in order to make that possible i think
it would be wise to put it in the bill
um
my other suggestion is that the gps or
whoever sent you off the vermont side to
haverhill
um you could have gone route 10 up to
newport but it would have taken three
times as long with the frosties right
senator khan
there is also the route 12 option yes
and more frosties
okay i got hit uh representative uh
somebody over here first had a hand up
just then representative uh
fort
go ahead represent ford and then
your mike
there we go thank you
some years ago when i was an academic
vice president we had a there was a
study done nationally
about the number of students in colleges
or schools of education
who completed the requirements to become
a teacher
and never applied for certification to
do the job
and it was something like half
of the students
so
that brings to me a different
perspective on
how are we going about preparing
teachers and toward what end and i think
that certainly is a significant part of
the issue that
you're
bringing this study
committee forward to
i think we need to look not only at
what's happening in the schools and all
the economic and other things that apply
but also
how are they being prepared and toward
what end
when more than half of them never apply
now it may well be as my wife says and
she prepared teachers that after they do
student teachers they realize they're in
the wrong career
because it's hard work and no one
pretends that otherwise
and
it's just that i think those issues need
to be factored in as well
as the usual culprits of salary and cost
and etc etc
now thank you representative ford and i
i think pipeline issues are
important to solving this issue and
[Music]
one thing that the time has
solved somewhat is that the
redistribution of who's attending
college and the fields that they are
graduating from has changed a lot in our
time in higher education
and
we know that
the schools of education have
their enrollments have plummeted
replaced by many other professions where
there is high need as well so
uh but i i think uh mr appleby
has a has a pulse on that and and i i
hope that the committee this commission
sorry this committee
would
would call upon college
of education deans
uh to to answer that kind of a question
representative
yeah thank you very much senator uh
representative cornell
thank you for taking my question this
may be a little anecdotal but i've been
hearing that numbers of teachers have
just been leaving during the school year
this year
just resigning and not caring do you
know if any kind of exit interviews have
been done with
any place to find out what's going on
why they're leaving um
you know i'm not even waiting to put in
their time for retirement or finishing
out the school year just saying
i i am not aware of that
the bill does anticipate that the
committee would would
try to reach to some forecast for
retirements
so that it's
it will do a look back to 2018
and then look forward to 2026
and try to get some good figures
uh on
thank you very much uh not seeing any
other hands thank you very much senator
thank you
steve in
yes steve are you here for technical
support or
if before we we have one other two but
are there questions from the committee
from the depart for the department on
rep representative nelson yes so mr
appleby
good morning representatives and thank
you steve appleby division director
educator support and higher education at
the department of ed
welcome representative nelson yes thank
you mr thank you mr chairman thank you
for taking my question
when did this trend when was it noticed
you know ten years ago five years ago
three and was any sense of what created
um
great question thank you i
i came to the department four years ago
um and
what i can i can speak to that four
years i can't speak to prior and i would
say that over the last four years we
have seen
you know every year that high number of
shortages in our survey um
as far as uh when it was noticed it i i
you know i think before i arrived at the
department it was a fairly high number
as well so i think this has been an
ongoing issue now for quite a number of
years
other questions representative luno sure
thank you very much mr chair thank you
very much mr appleby um do uh does the
uh does the department um also track
i guess availability of qualified
administrators
you know that qualified to serve as
superintendents or building principals
uh in the state
thank you for the question so um our
survey does survey
um
as senator khan mentioned approximately
54 endorsements some of those are
administrator endorsements our survey is
driven by the u.s uh department of ed
because we report the numbers back to
them
yes represent moffat
thank you mr chair thank you for your uh
testimony for being here so as i look at
the language of this
we see specific mention of loan
forgiveness housing assistance tuition
reimbursement scholarships to help fill
shortages
now
i know that the shortages are not uh
the same in different disciplines some
some disciplines are acute shortages and
some i have a social science background
and i taught that and there was never
such demand for that
uh candidly as there was for
language or math or
certain sciences
so
my question is
what about
um bonus incentives it's not mentioned
in the language here and i understand
that the the uh the unions or whatever
uh
don't like that approach but what do you
think about bonuses for targeted
disciplines where there are acute
shortages
thank you for the question i think that
there are probably any number of options
especially senator khan mentioned
there's a lot of work being done in
other states that run the range from
scholarships for
educator preparation programs to
registered apprenticeships to bonuses
and signing bonuses i've discussed that
with numerous superintendents
that option so there are a full range of
tools i think being tried in other
states i mean i just got an article this
morning that montana is testing out a
four day week uh in its schools as a
retention attraction retention tool for
educators and i know that's also being
done in either alabama or mississippi so
the beautiful thing about our country
right is that
people experiment so there's lots of
different options i think that i think
that that study committee can can look
at
thank you
steve i was talking to a young man in
ocean
state the other day
had graduated from uvm with a degree in
english
i asked him had anybody ever suggested
to you while you were in college that
you should be getting a teacher's ticket
at the same time he said no
um we have a lot of that going on where
you major in political science or
history or music or and you come out
without that teacher credential
i know when i attended the university of
maine it was mandatory in certain
programs if you're going to major in pe
you also got your certification in
another area as well
is there any effort on the part of the
department to work with higher education
to
let them know that the these
students that are in the liberal arts
areas or any other area might be wise
just to hook on to that teacher ticket
while you're at school save some dollars
thank you for the question i represent
chair um i think you know those
discussions have occurred at the council
of teacher education in those meetings
around expanding the number of students
in their programs and trying to also
reach out to students not in their
programs but who are
pursuing degrees in liberal arts those
discussions have happened but there's
been nothing formal
to my knowledge thank you further
questions yes representatives
has there been any discussion about
rewarding particularly good students
with higher pay as opposed to just
working on the
you know you've been here so long you
get x amount of money but actually
giving some sort of
bonus or higher pay or whatever to
particularly good student i mean
thank you
not that i'm aware of but i wouldn't
necessarily be aware of that as that's
an employment
issue in the districts but i have not
heard any discussion of that
thank you
i can say that's a very difficult thing
as a school administrator
i could not keep a science teacher on
staff bp or arco
any of them on the north slope just
picked them up and paid them 10 times
when i could pay them in the school
district
represent porter
thank you just kind of to answer your
question and maybe for information i
believe there have been studies done
um on the effect of merit pay
satisfaction and it
un
surprisingly fails miserably according
to the studies that i've seen it's not a
it's not a motivator
for teachers
it's what i understand
thank you we have one more pink card
here are there any other questions for
well we can get it from you
thank you very much steve
uh last one is brian hawkins
anya
welcome thank you mr chairman it's good
to be back
in house education i think it's only
been a couple of weeks
since i was here every day with you with
all of you but it feels like a lifetime
um
for the record brian hawkins uh today
representing nea new hampshire
um want to thank senator con
in support of senate bill 236 i want to
thank senator khan senator ward and the
senate education committee for the for
the bipartisan endorsement of this bill
this is one of the critical issues that
we need to be
focused on going forward and so i think
the timing of this is is is very good um
as was noted earlier uh school staffing
shortages are not new but we are seeing
them um you know across every job
category
uh in education and um
you know
this is obviously a critical need for
for the people who matter in this
equation the most the students uh what
we certainly saw during the pandemic
that we need
to be in person
we need to have the teachers in front of
those kids
to do that too
and so
senator connell already brought up the
issue of the critical shortage lists
that we know about
a couple of
pieces of information some of which i'll
are at the national level just to
highlight the need at the national level
there was a report done
recently using statistics from the
bureau of labor statistics job openings
and
labor turnover survey and the
hires to job openings ratio fell below
0.5 for the for the second time ever
which indicates that the challenge is
facing public educa education employers
in filling positions
remains formidable and the number so the
number of educators
uh quitting the profession continue
uh continues to track on the 12-year
trend line that began back in 2009
um
and and uh this trend has seen the
typical
uh
quit rate rise from 0.4
per month in august 2009 to 1.1 per
month in february 2022.
uh the number of educators
uh in local public education so this is
pre-k
through 12 remains uh below pre-pandemic
levels by about 331 000 jobs nationally
or 4.1
and then when you talk about the at the
state level for for higher education
um there's a deficit there as uh as well
um the the the other thing i would just
like to highlight from this is um
we you know we have had growth uh
nationally in in local public education
three
three consecutive months of losses
in higher ed but in in in at the local
level
as i said there's still uh
several hundred thousand fewer educators
employed to the today than there were
prior to the pandemic
um
and so it just to look at that at the
growth rate even though we're seeing
growth over the last several months
um it um it would take 18 months for
local public education nationally to get
back to where we were
at february 2020 employment levels i
realize these are national levels but i
think national numbers
but
and we would be happy to work with this
committee to really drill down locally
and be a resource for this committee
some of you may have seen uh there was a
recent poll done
in look looking forward and why this
committee is important um
nea pulled its members
nationally uh over 3 600 surveys
uh
scientific polls so
more than half 55 percent of members say
that they are more likely to leave
or retire from education sooner than
planned
because of the pandemic
and that's
that's almost double the number saying
the same in july of 2020. so a lot of
concern i have no doubt there is a lot
of that in new hampshire
we
fully support this
committee and i said as i said would be
happy to work and be a resources to it
to help it uh succeed so with that i'll
uh take any questions and i did notice
in reviewing the bill this morning
um that there was still as senator khan
said i was happy to see that there's
still two senators on there who'll be
attending the study activity so
thank you very much brian uh i noticed
that while you're speaking you had a
sheet which you were taking all that
information from statistics could you
provide that to the clerk or yes i have
i have uh hard copies i'll drop off with
the clerk thank you very much yes are
there questions from brian hawkins
thank you
um other than covid
have you heard any specific order that
tend to be any patterns of reasons why
teachers
leave before retirement time have you
heard any specific complaints or
anything that are things that could be
addressed
um
thank you for the question
and actually i think that ties into the
the piece about the staffing shortage
that was was a problem even before the
pandemic i mean i think uh you're well
aware that
the pandemic
shed light or exacerbated a lot of
problems that we have in our local
schools and staffing was certainly one
of them it didn't
any of the whether it's in new hampshire
or
any of the
nationally uh a lot of the
uh any closures that we might see right
now aren't related to
so much to directly to covid but if
covid takes out you know five
five teachers the staff from here you
know we were already at that um
uh sort of the brink in a lot of schools
for hiring um so uh that's a sort of
long way of saying i think staffing
issues overall having
some of the the
survey that was
done
by nea indicated that there's a lot more
you're doing just a lot more jobs that
don't involve your ability to focus on
uh you know during lunch time you're
you've got to cover stuff in the
cafeteria instead of you know reviewing
your lesson plans and things like that
so um so i think that's some of the
things that that that existed even pre
pandemic that you know are just are
still there and contributing to the
problem
reps and cordelli
oh wow thank you mr chairman uh thank
you uh for being here again um just
wonder if you know of any schools in new
hampshire that do exit interviews
i don't know the answer to that question
i believe that there are but um i'd be
happy to to get you more information
about that um i could certainly survey
some of our our various locals and and
see
see that
speaking from
experience
do you feel
that
setting class b felony convictions for
different
violations by teachers uh political
intrusions and restrictions that have
been recently
set into
or presented as rsas
or even just as bills or for example the
loyalty oath
type of bill
how much do you think that affects uh
teachers decisions when they get to be
about
60 years old uh whether they want to
really stick around or not
i was going to say that uh as you were
as you were posing
thinking as you were posing the question
that
you know
there's so many factors contributing
when when people are reaching that uh
point
uh i don't i don't think it helps i i
will say just anecdotally i i have
talked to some recent retired
uh teachers who some of them would say
boy am i am i glad that i'm retired now
and i think that includes some of the
issues that you raised that you know as
well as the pandemic and and and all of
the the things that have
uh
you know resulted
because of that
there's so many issues in in education
so i think i think that's where
i think that's where this
getting into it with the study committee
will help is we can talk about all of
those
yep
one last question then we have to move
on to the next
revision like
two questions okay representative then
left represent
i just wondered if you could get us that
information from the studies that were
done beforehand that talked about the
various things that teachers complain
about like
doing extra things like lunch duty and
that kind of stuff could you get us the
results of that uh certainly so it it um
you know it doesn't drill down as
specific as you know uh
i'll i will i will get you the survey so
that you can see what it indicates
representative mullin thank you mr chair
and thank you uh mr hawkins for taking
my question
looking at the other end of a career
the beginning yes
um
in terms of average starting teacher
salaries in new hampshire you know let's
say within the first five years or
whatever and
what we know about affordable housing
shortages
is it
possible for uh
a
work within the public school settings
and
live a life that doesn't require either
living with their parents or uh
finding some sort of alternative
arrangement
i think that's a i think that is a big
challenge particularly as as as we look
at you know student you know continuing
to have student loans so
housing certainly being a pressure for
all of us but
uh i think the student loan issue is a
big big
uh
you know has an impact and when people
are doing the dollars and cents of how
to start their career
i do i do think that that is an impact
and that's one of the
data points i think
the salary issue that
i know the the school funding commission
looked at across the state where our
starting salaries where are you going to
be in five years
uh if you start that and and the
disparity um when you go from
you know pittsburgh to salem
and or you know
even the next town over so
definitely in an uh
[Music]
a big component of it that i think um
and and something that i hope the
committee will look at
could i just ask just one quick yeah
it's not even a follow-up question it's
just a request um if you when you're
gathering your data for us could uh give
us an idea of some of those points of
information you know starting
compensation
disparity whatever i i would find that
helpful absolutely and represent moffitt
sorry mr chair um
and thank you for being here we do
notice our season ticket holders who are
here uh regularly like yourself i know i
noticed it doesn't really come with any
other
benefits
so my real quick question we might be
getting into the weeds a little bit
stuff that would go to the committee if
there is a committee but i did want to
ask
because i think it's significant uh
enrollment has gone down significantly
it's documented uh varies from community
community
uh ten percent it depends but does
declining enrollment mitigate in any way
the teacher shortage in your view
uh i don't not from what i've heard uh
you know i think it's district by
district
in terms of uh you know the impact that
uh you know a couple of staff or a
couple of teachers leaving can can can
have on a particular schools you know
some of it's the size of the
school district um so
uh
you know
i i i think that um i think it's uh an
issue in the prevent
in the profession and
uh you know as we as the study committee
uh commences i think that's something
that you know be
when we look at it at a district level i
think that'll that'll that will be also
a an interest a an important data point
uh to look at is when we look at by
district uh
representative waltz
um my question is do you think we should
be amending this bill to include the
words compensation study because that's
really what we're talking about and i
think we need to be clear and i think
it's a huge factor in teacher retention
and even people entering the field and
i'm wondering if we want to make that a
specific requirement of the study
well we can we can amend and do anything
we want with that bill uh when we get to
the session where we do that there's a
lot of issues you know for example are
are people retiring because i'm now
vested in the system i'm eligible for
all those retirement benefits i'm going
to get out now after eight or nine years
not do my 20 because i'm vested uh i
think all these compensations issues
wrap into a good question should we be
studying that more thoroughly probably
yes
so
i agree with you
wrap san luna
thank you mr chair and um
and and uh following on representative
moffat's question with respect to
enrollment uh when the when the
department reported the um the uh the
total enrollment the adm for uh for the
current um school year following the
october first
enrollment the uh
the the numbers were down substantially
i think that's what uh what
representative moffatt was was referring
to uh certainly some of that may be
pandemic related but um but we don't
know where a lot of these kids are
either and um and they uh they did not
uh at least based on the efa numbers
go into those programs go into other
other programs and i think this may be
something uh independent of um
of senate bill 236 that this committee
may want to
take a look at you know more more
closely
and uh and uh
following you know maybe as we come out
of the pandemic as well
but um but just to be sure that um that
we're not uh
that we're not losing um
kids uh or that kids are not being being
educated we've been losing kids for
years and years here and so is higher ed
no no demographic i'm talking about the
precipitous drop-off that that appeared
to be pandemic related
we were having a precipitous drop-off
when i got in here we had 220 000 kids k
through 12. now we're down what 160 170
somewhere in there
so and it's not all pandemic we no
nobody's dropping off no no but i'm
talking i'm just talking about the the
the specific numbers from fy
21 to fy22
um
and uh and just just taking a look at
that because i think that did not
follow the the trend line that uh that
had been you know uh
built up over a decade or more
it's just something that i think this
committee may want to take a look at
we we can look at all the information
once if this community is going i'm sure
they can
thank you mr chair
further questions of brian hawkins thank
you very much brian thank you mr
chairman
i don't have any other pink cards on
this one so we'll close this hearing
and um
somebody has to stand up and stretch a
little bit
um
go ahead and stretch for
four or four minutes here and then we'll
i had a lot of teachers where i was
before who were once they became vested
in the system and they had a retirement
they they left
earned big money with industry came back
and bought in years that they'd had in
the military etc and
a
use of the registry established by the
national association of state directors
teacher education and certification
so that there can be
a
look
at the licensing
that may have occurred for a candidate
seeking licensure in new hampshire
what their status might have been in
another state
and that's why this cross-state registry
is being suggested by the department to
put into the enabling act relative to
its licensing function
you should have in front of you
an amendment that
i hope somebody in the committee would
uh bring forward
that uh adjusts uh item three in the
bill
uh
that
uh also anticipates that
uh
some of the the
sharing of registry information could be
an intergovernmental compact
and this is
again authorizing legislation that would
enable the department to work with the
governor and executive council
to
enable
that kind of reciprocity to be entered
into
so that's the nature of the bill and i'm
glad that
attorney diana fenton and director
uh appleby are both here to to speak to
the bill thank you very much senator are
there questions from senator khan
or to senator khan
not seeing any
representative porter
thank you mr chair this is maybe more
for you than for senator khan
um the amendment that he brought forward
we have to have a house version of this
is that right we cannot amend this bill
with the senate amendment that that's
correct
i think i asked uh senator khan to
present that though so we could see it
and have in front of us and we'd know
what he was referencing and speaking
about thank you very much
and it had to be presented by somebody
on this committee
yes representative waltz
thank you i i'm just trying
i'm like to this game so i'm trying to
understand this section four the
establishment of educator certification
fees
are there currently fees
yes
so
[Music]
it's just a grammatical change but the
establishment of in there it doesn't
change anything
okay just trying to understand this
because if it was new fees it should go
to finance and that's why i'm asking
okay thanks
the department does this through rules
uh the fees we'll ask mr appleby
good idea good idea
yes
thank you very much are there further
yes representative nelson thank you mr
chairman thank you senator for taking my
question seems like a silly one but are
they checking i'm looking at number
three the establishment implications
secure system of accessing findings of
abuse for individuals is this the
teacher being abused
or
the teacher applying for a job being
abused and i'm confused as to who's
being abused
i think i know but
well judging from the you'll this is a
good question for the department for for
attorney thank you yeah
judging from this section
yes representatives
thank you the amendment that you gave us
is this a new one that you came up since
this was passed in the senate correct it
was presented to me by the department
thank you
further questions
of senator
khan
thank you very much senator thank you mr
chairman okay well
um steve appleby
and i i don't know if uh diana
do you have to be here too or can we do
okay
okay both are here for technical
assistance are there questions of the
thank you um
the naz naz tech
we're all already a member of that group
yes we are okay um
so uh
we haven't been doing um
a check of applicants through that
organization is that what i'm
understanding
uh uh
no sorry for the confusion i'm steve
appleby division director department of
ed um
what this what we're adding in here is
the use of social security numbers so
today
we do check the list
and we do ask for social security
numbers but in full disclosure there was
nothing in statute that told us we could
so uh
uh jail car suggested we add that
okay to a statue but we have been
checking we've been a member for
probably decades okay i i just in the
meantime had looked up their website um
and they have a educator misconduct look
up
on there and new hampshire's not
participating in that um is there any
reason that we're not participating in
it
i was unaware of that we are
oh so i will check with them okay yeah
it's not listed on on their area so but
that's one of the things that that will
help us
uh as far as criminal background checks
and and checks with
people coming into the state
thank you
and just to add to that for the record
diana fenton i'm an attorney for the
department of ed
new hampshire is a member of nasdaq
nasdaq is the national group that tracks
educator misconduct so while the state
of new hampshire through the department
of ed maintains
the revoked and suspended educator list
the national group is nasdaq and states
can be members new hampshire is an
active participating member we have been
checking nasdaq routinely and regularly
however the law provides that if we use
social security numbers
which we can we can either check by date
of birth or social security numbers
there's a law that says if you use
social security numbers you have to put
that in your you have to have statutory
statutory authority to do so so that's
are there further questions of the
department
i'm i'm happy to address representative
nelson's question that he asked of
senator khan yeah that that'd be fine
and we'll have reps and luna after
representative nelson's question
um so to address the amendment um that
senator khan kindly brought forward
this would give the department of
education access to other states
uh dcyf for their or their equivalent
the division of children youth and
families they're central registries for
abuse and neglect this legislative body
last session uh passed a law which
allowed the department of education to
work with its sister state agency dcyf
to gain access to the central registry
it's important to recognize that
findings on the central registry for
abuse
are not necessarily criminal they are
administrative so they would not
necessarily show up on a criminal
background check
for either employment or credentialing
purposes the department felt that it was
a kind of a common sense safe measure to
work with our sister state agency
while we were working on that bill and
putting that in place and we're
continuing to work on building that
infrastructure
we were advised that an individual from
massachusetts who was on the
massachusetts dcf their their version of
dcyf their central registry came to new
hampshire and is licensed to teach
in the state of new hampshire and was
employed as a teacher in the state of
new hampshire
we took the measures that we had to
internally to address that situation but
in doing so we began talking to our
counterparts in massachusetts and they
agreed to work with us to allow
the new hampshire department of
education access to the massachusetts
gcf registry
it's a pretty exciting step to be honest
with you because
the massachusetts department of
education doesn't even have access to
that list i hope this isn't being
recorded and watched in massachusetts
so we i think are in a unique position
all jokes notwithstanding to to really
strengthen um the security by which we
issue a credential and it's important to
recognize that school districts don't
have access to the central registry of
dcyf that
they're not a sister state agency they
can't access that but the department can
and so when we look at this language
representative nelson to address your
question we would be looking at the
applicant's name to see if the applicant
has had a finding of abuse in either new
hampshire dcyf or massachusetts dcf
registry
you follow up thank you mr chairman
so if i was a child and i was abused yes
would that show up
by name most likely not um the names of
the individuals are either abbreviated
or redacted but when we have access to
the central registry and to be honest
with you i've never
personally seen the central registry the
reason is i'm not authorized
we limit within our mou we limit the
authorization to have access to it so we
at the department of education had to
sign some agreements confidentiality
agreements it's covered in the
memorandum
i don't have access to it i'm not one of
the authorized people who has access
same thing with massachusetts but i can
assure you both states take the
precautions they have to to
deal with that situation but what what
we're looking for
is the name of the person who is
applying to teach we're not looking for
the details of the offense
can i
just
thank you
i guess how it's worded it's just i'm
sorry for a quick crazy question like
you're going after i understand as a
teacher
have i ever i assume have you ever
abused anybody
but how it's reading
you could say was i ever abused as a
by somebody else
growing up i'm not a teach
so i i appreciate that question and um
i
i have uh from time to time been guilty
of really bad writing so i appreciate
the opportunity to look at it i think
when and i'm happy to to reword it um
but when you look at it in totality it's
looking for a finding of abuse
for people who are applying to teach and
so when i think i think when you look at
it outside of this amendment and put it
in totality hopefully it makes sense but
i appreciate you bringing that to my
attention happy to work on that
representative
thank you very much mr chairman and
actually the um the the the back and
forth uh between representative nelson
and um and attorney fenton i think um
uh helped address uh my uh
uh you know questions that that that i
was thinking but um but um attorney
fenton you do refer to the the the
nasdaq as as as essentially having
findings they're not necessarily
criminal but their findings correct do
they does it also contain anything
prior to a finding maybe that an
investigation is pending or hasn't been
completed on a uh on an individual
it
it could yes so my understanding of
nasdaq um
and
it's unique because every state
puts their own information in and so
every state kind of has their own rules
by by which
they decide what they enter
but for example with new hampshire if
someone is under investigation and that
is a term of art pursuant to our
administrative rules we enter that
person into nasdaq so other states would
see that that person is under
investigation um
and then when that investigation is
closed if it's not founded we remove
them if it's founded we make that that
notation
and i know other states probably follow
similar guidelines
and other states might just put in the
findings
great thank you very much thank you
uh
steve
on the amendment or diane um
i'm i'm trying to
figure out why we have to you know to
access findings of abuse of these
individuals we have to have an mou by
the governor and
council
uh when we could put that in statute or
some you know
why why this route that you've got here
and and
how would that mou be
put together
yeah so thank you for the question um
the reason for the approval by governor
and council is because we have to
recognize this is an interstate
agreement it is not just new hampshire
doe working with new hampshire dcyf this
is the state of new hampshire entering
into an agreement with the state of
massachusetts and that's why my
understanding is the governor and
council
approval is required
in terms of the memorandum of
understanding i can tell you that
that is a great document for
for the department to have it really
lays out it's kind of a contract
right it's it's somewhat of a contract
it lays out the understanding from both
parties and we have both commissioners
sign it even though not uh i don't think
it was required but we entered into a
memorandum of understanding with new
hampshire dcyf to just lay out
how this was going to work and what the
expectations of both parties were so as
a practical matter i think it really
helps facilitate
the end objective and the end goal um
and it is the state version of a
contract for lack of a better term
so
so we're going to have to possibly set
up mousse with
49 states
well we're going to start with one
with massachusetts i i don't know if the
vision
is
having this be nationwide we have we
have entered into a discussion with
massachusetts and massachusetts has
agreed to do this um but other states
don't have to do this when i went to
write this law i will tell you i was
kind of stymied because i i said to my
co-counsel i said i can't write a law
that binds another state
i can't write a law that says
massachusetts shall
enter into this agreement
and so this was the best language i
could come up with i don't know if the
vision is to
expand this to all 50 states
but it certainly would be the
department's hope to start with
massachusetts and potentially add on
maine and vermont
for our purposes
of licensing people
that
that makes comments it's a common sense
approach
uh to this situation that we're dealing
with
it's too bad it's not a national deal we
we know with our intergovernmental
uh
school districts those are approved by
congress
not through an mou
and if we're dealing with teacher
applicants or folks we're looking at
from all over this country uh it seems
to me wouldn't it be wiser to have
something done on the national level
maybe through one of these organizations
you're speaking of uh
then to do it individually you know with
maine and then mass and then everybody
else
you know ideally my wish list would be
that we could work on a national level
on this
um
and i think maybe someday that's
possible but working with the here and
now with what we have i think this is a
really great start and when we share
this idea with other people
they
they go oh yeah
why wouldn't you have access to new
hampshire dcyf and in massachusetts it's
a great opportunity and so um i do think
massachusetts has given us a wonderful
opportunity i would be remiss if we
missed that that chance um and maybe
someday it could go on a national level
uh we're just not there quite yet well
we do have a federal
doe we do
okay
if you keep giving me different ranks
maybe i could i could approach them so
well you want to be governor
no
okay represent lekkas
thank you
i was just looking at the wording and i
don't know if this actually makes sense
but
i was wondering if you changed in line
for the word for to buy
it would be findings of abuse by
individuals
on the central registry it all depends
upon where you put your commas which
so
i i appreciate that i think you might
have just solved my problem okay thank
you thank you for the word smithing
that's right
i'll take all the help
are there further questions from the
department
uh we don't have any other cards on 350
up here
so we'll close this
and go into um
352.
welcome again representative khan
yep
you're going to speak 10 minutes on this
one
we'll do what your your group does
you could stop listening after the first
one
thank you mr chairman
senator jay khan
from keene
and
the reason this came forward is we have
been
adjusting
uh
our procedure for
we've been doing that
in
at least the last few years
last four years and
i'm sure the department probably feels
like it's every year
and
they've been doing that in collaboration
with the department of safety
so that they can do those criminal
history background checks uh do the fbi
check
across the state and by the way you also
have
president today kristen shea from the
department of
safety so
query
their processes for sharing this
information with the department of
education
for
certification and licensure purposes you
what
the department called to my attention
was that
uh
we were
i mean you know the problem that there
is with substitute teachers uh we we
know that
uh districts have really struggled
during the pandemic to
to have sufficient coverage
and
uh substitute teachers are often trying
to fill in their schedule
by
offering to be
uh substitutes in multiple schools
and those schools could be in multiple
districts but under the same sau
and this bill tries to
anticipate that kind of situation
that a sau and that school
superintendent
could do that background check
maintain that record of the background
check and then that teacher could be
authorized
to substitute
at any of the
locations school buildings
uh within that sau
so that's the intention here i hope the
words and the
punctuation is uh
adequately done to uh
and i'll claim that i've read this more
often uh than anyone else and should
have caught them if uh
but
[Music]
the department is here to uh and diana
fenton i think is the
person who worked this out with
different uh education organizations to
bring this forward to the senate
so we're glad to answer any questions
but i think the department's in a good
position to answer those thank you mr
chairman thank you very much are there
questions for
senators khan
yes representative cornell thank you and
i don't know if this question is for you
is there a reason why is it isn't across
other saus
i i think
i i don't i can't answer okay
i have a similar type question where we
use substitutes where i am that come
from the other side the river
so
is there any if a criminal
check is done in vermont
is that good for just coming across the
river and working here i see
ms shea back there shaking her head no
um
okay
uh
further questions from the committee
not seeing any is there any desire to
have the department of state yes
represent i knew you'd be the first one
very good
thank you very much senator thank you mr
chairman
welcome
thank you chairman and members of the
committee is this on red is on right
okay um my name is vic mazzy i'm a
captain with the state police in charge
of the justice information bureau which
includes
the criminal records unit
um so i think we've got two questions
i'll let you decide who wants to ask
first or well if you just want to speak
to some of those things that we're
discussing sure certainly so i think the
one question is um
the distribution of records if you will
from one sau to the other
at the moment the fbi won't allow that
we're at their mercy so as it stands now
there is a representative in an
alternate for each siu which has been
authorized by the fbi to receive the
records for that sau
so unless
we worked out the details with the fbi
we wouldn't be able to share between
districts
nor would we be able to share between
states i guess is the other part of that
question
okay representative mullen
thank you mr chair and thank you for
coming in to answer questions for us
today so my question is somewhat related
to representative cornell's question uh
i understand that the fbi is in charge
of that decision
are there any industries or professions
i mean certainly education can't be the
only one where somebody contracts for
providing services from town to town i
mean is there in your estimation is
there a way that we can
craft something that would allow
a speech pathologist to go from
community to community without requiring
a background check in every community
that they work in
presently no
um unless it was worked out through the
department of ed but i don't want to
speak for them
well we have the attorney coming up
right beside you sprinting printing as
best i can
um
hi i missed everyone in the two minutes
i was sitting down
for the record diana fenton i'm an
attorney with the department of
education um that is a question that has
been posed to the department many times
and i believe there was a
house bill
brought forward that would establish
that steady commission
to look at that exact issue
of
professionals or individuals who are
going from district to district and and
could the department of education play a
centralized role
in helping to facilitate that
um
and so hopefully that will pass and be
something that
representative mullin and i will be
working on this summer together
committee
but this bill
just deals with the substitute teachers
and it deals with a unique situation
where they work in the same sau they
work within one sau but there are
multiple
school boards and and districts within
that sau and so
it is a situation that was brought to
the department's attention by the school
boards association
and we worked with them to address this
and try to craft this solution
recognizing that we need substitute
teachers and we need substitute teachers
who have mobility
and so this is kind of a small step to
address
a big problem
and it would be limited to only that sau
to alleviate substitute teachers from
having to undergo multiple checks within
one sau and at the same time
our hope is that it does not violate any
of the
fbi regulations because there is no
dissemination of the record it's all
housed within the sau it's just
recognizing that this person has been
cleared and and it's not necessary to
representative moffitt
thank you miss sheriff and uh thank you
for taking my question i know if this is
best addressed to captain mazzy or
ambassador fenton or the or the uh prime
sponsor but
uh so you have a
a substitute teacher who has been
cleared by one or more districts or saus
or whatever so they've had their
background check and they're cleared and
they go on spring break to florida and
they get into trouble you can fill in
the blank but some felony that that
they're charged with and convicted of in
florida or wherever
so
um if
does this
this conviction
a felony conviction
scenario
did the folks in new hampshire ever find
out about that um
do you see
my question here i do um and that's an
issue that is discussed
quite a bit when this topic comes up i
think the short answer to your question
is
no based on that scenario that person
could come back go back to work and
it would not necessarily be known
in all fairness there is a program at
dos is it rat back or wrap back yes
which one's a wrap
wrap back
so there's a program
program called rap
back and some states no new hampshire is
not one of them
but there is a program and i think in a
few years this legislative body will
hear of it there is a program by which
those out-of-state offenses would be
automatically sent
to the state where the individual holds
a license
and some states participate in that
program so for example the state of
pennsylvania
every monday the new the pennsylvania
department of education gets a list
of licensed professionals whether it's
teachers or lawyers or whatever who have
been arrested
in the state of pennsylvania
and that's part of their program of
maintaining their licensure
and other states have it
on a national level that they would
receive that information
new hampshire is not one of them but my
understanding is that something dos is
thank you representative tanner
thank you and thank you for taking my
question so you're talking about
substitutes that have
the same employer so for example like um
well keirsarger
you know that has eight towns in their
district and they have an elementary
school in like three different towns and
whatever but the superintendent
basically is in charge
of the district and is the
employer i mean the school board's the
employer but the superintendent would be
the person that does the
receives receives the criminal
background check so
what you're saying is this bill simply
states in statute that if they're within
that district
um and and where you have like the
dresden district up in
in hanover
uh you have norwich vermont and hanover
new hampshire but they have the same
employer
is that
does that apply there as well
correct i think that it would i mean the
example that the school boards
association always gives us the
come join us you stay right there okay
come right in the middle sorry
uh becky wilson school boards
association so the the catalyst for this
bill really is that the criminal
background check for sau employees that
um
you know siu 24 for example is made up
of stoddard john stark henniker and ware
school districts but there's only one
designee or superintendent who obtains
the criminal background check for a
substitute employee for all of those
school districts
and because the same person previously
the way the current rule is has to apply
for that criminal background check for
that substitute for each district the
same person is getting the exact same
report four or five times um and then
bringing that information not the actual
physical
background check but just the
information from that to the multiple
school boards to get permission to hire
that person
so we're trying to just eliminate
the same person getting multiple
copies and having to pay the fee for
example to get the additional copies for
the information that they got two days
ago for the same person so that that
person can sub at where and then the
next day sub in henniker
it's just it's not about
multiple people getting copies of the
criminal background check it's not about
the copies going anywhere it's just that
the same person and that designee is
what a complex issue uh if i'm um
working in a
career technical education center
and we're talking about regional
agreements now which may involve
multiple multiple different districts
um
how's that going to how is the getting a
substitute going to relate
in terms of
if they're approved in one of those
sending districts are they good for all
the other districts because they're all
part of that regional agreement
thank you for the question cte centers i
think would be a little bit different
however the employ who is the employer
would be the question and what school
board would approve that person's
contract even though the substitute
may only be getting one criminal
background check and that's going to one
superintendent each district still is
hiring that person under a separate
contract potentially or under a
substitute contract so it would really
that person would not travel for example
from crtc to sugar river valley as a
substitute those are two totally
different employers
and different um completely different
saus so those
career technical ed centers are still
covered under those saus and they would
still need two different background
checks crazy
represent litchfield
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
so i understand the legislation
definitely based on what i'm hearing i
definitely support it i just wanted to
go back to representative moffett's
question
so and regarding this wrap back program
so right now as it stands with these
substitutes they'll be checked again
under this bill every three years is
that correct so we may not catch it near
two or three but we would catch it at
the third year and then i just wanted to
clarify we've discussed it before and
i'm drawing a blank
any of our
teachers or certified staff that we hire
do we run the background check when
they're initially hired but we don't do
that again or is that based on
individual school policy yeah okay um
that would be a good question for the
department as we move into the cycles of
uh criminal background checks being with
the licensing piece but yes i mean
when you first are employed you are
getting that criminal background check
through your employer
may i follow up go ahead
um may i just ask how we came up with
the the three year point to check it why
not two or whatever that's the cycle for
your license chair through the
department in terms of your educational
license it's good for three years
thank you you're welcome
well
what happened if you have a life ticket
i
i wish that thank you for the question i
wish there was such a thing i have five
department of beds
make up in three years any time nelson
great
thank you very much mr chairman and
thank you for taking my question
as a retired special ed teacher i live
near three
saus
so i go through the process to go to one
of them and they only want me three days
a week and all of a sudden i get called
from another one would i come it's an
emergency situation
i have to wait for the
check to go through how long does that
all take
uh thank you for the question some of
that might be a department of safety
question it really depends i think on
capacity of doing the criminal
background checks
time of year plays a big part of that we
often
when we're hiring people at the sau
level in the fall
or in august the background checks take
longer because there's a lot of
districts that are doing a lot of hiring
during that time
it just really depends on
capacity thank you thank you further
questions representative cornell
don't
saus or schools only call people who are
on their pre-approved sub-list
thank you for the question you would not
be able to hire someone as a substitute
if they weren't already employed by the
district which would require going
through these channels of having to have
it's the same process for bus drivers
uh it's just thank you for the question
it's a little bit different and i would
defer that to the department because now
they're overseeing background checks for
bus drivers
so can you get a substitute bus driver
that's not
in the district driving for you there's
been a real shortage of drivers here in
our state
i mean that's really a question for the
department but they are overseeing the
bus drivers again you would still have
to follow whatever process it is to be
approved as a bus driver for that
district
a law was passed
by a legislative session
which
centralized
the
criminal history record clearance for
bus driver within the department of
education to address your issue of
mobility to allow bus driver to
work as substitute subscribers in other
districts
thank you
further questions
not cnn thank you very much thank you
are there any other cards pink cards for
okay we have no other cards and we have
one other bill here prior to lunch
353 relative to education professional
you need 30 seconds here
clark needs 30 seconds to get the
does this mean if a bill
gets
heard
oh good welcome senator again again
jay khan still from keene
i do know how to get there
uh
the uh and back it's not getting there
it's getting away from there yeah
um
i'm gonna i'm gonna ask representative
ladd to accompany me to a
governor and council transportation
this bill was requested by the
department uh the edge you can see what
the composition is of the
uh professional
standards board
that they use to maintain the standards
of
people who have been licensed
this is just a
because the membership of the commission
is
in statute
this bill is brought forward
to make sure that members can serve
that's on line 17
[Music]
it also
is making some adjustments to the 21
members
uh
but
uh the the real intent here is that what
i've heard mr appleby describe
previously uh
people get familiar with their duties in
one or two
terms on the standards board
and their real
payback is when they serve a third term
and
are very familiar and can mentor the
other
new newbies coming onto the board so
that's the intent uh
nothing
nothing too monumental here okay
are there questions of the senator
representatives
just for my own
personal edification
can you explain the difference between
education specialists and instructional
specialists
uh
no
okay
but i gotta notice that somebody can
any other questions thank you very much
steve
hello again uh thank you steve appleby
division director department of
education
so to answer your question um an
instructional specialist would be for
example a reading writing specialist who
works with teachers on improving their
their practice of how they teach reading
and writing an educational specialist
for example would be a guidance
counselor
who is an educator educator being an
umbrella term but they don't actually
teach a class
typically
thank you
typically typically school psychologist
are you satisfied with that response
i'm glad you are
represent tanner
i'm not quite satisfied with this
response
um
so uh
you've got nine members representing
classroom teachers
um
and it says or educational you've
crossed out or
educational specialists and i understand
those are people who are going to be
working in a school
is that correct
and then instructional specialists
does that include like people from
prenda that are working in the micro
schools or people who are working in
charter schools who are perhaps
not certified
good question thank you and and no we
actually have a category for late people
who are not certified
so there are several seats for lay folks
uh on the psp the the
the intent of line 10 of adding that
language we've been trying to
update our terminology and our statutes
and rules now for several years to be
more in line nationally with what's used
around the country makes it easier for
licensed reciprocity and talking to
other states and this is just part of
that ongoing three sb 350 had some
terminology adjustments as well so this
is just updating the terminology and
making sure that we're not excluding
certain classes of license holders under
the current statute we're excluding
instructional specialists
so the intent here was just to add that
in so that
those folks can serve as well
can i have a follow-up yes go ahead
so
when you talked about instructional
specialists before
it sounded like um it included
consultants
um
to
uh come in to help teachers teach
for example reading
that perhaps they would have for
professional development classes or uh
so um reading writing specialists for
example that is a licensed
uh position yes so we hand out a license
for reading writing specialist
math specialists we have a license so
that's what that's referring to is those
licensed individuals who work in a
school and work with teachers but are
not themselves directly teaching okay
and just one other follow-up
so i i quickly went on the professional
standards boards
and there's quite a there's like three
vacancies under that particular part
and two vacancies under higher ed
educational administration
um can you explain why there
are possibly vacancies and what can be
done to fill those vacancies
yes
thank you for the question so um you
know one of the issues that we've run
into the last several years is you know
this is a fairly significant time
commitment of those who volunteer to be
on the professional standards board and
certainly um with with the pandemic and
everyone being
really pulled in many many directions we
saw a drop-off in applicants we've since
seen that pick back up and there are
actually a number of applications at the
state board level uh waiting to be
vetted
and and reviewed by the state board and
voted on so i would anticipate those
vacancies over the next few months will
be filled
for the ball
are there further questions uh mr
appleby yes represent luno thank you
very much mr chair um as a as a
follow-on to representative tanner's um
question
uh and i and i may be getting at
existing language as opposed to
you know amended language but looking at
lines 9 and 10
um
in
roman 1b
nine members representing classroom
teachers education specialists or
that could
would it be your interpretation of that
line that um that that could mean nine
members representing just instructional
specialists
yes that would be possible however the
state board would have to appoint them
so
but that would be possible okay would so
a follow-up on that yes what would it
would it would it be more consistent
with the legislative intent
of
of lines nine and ten
for the nine members
to be representing classroom teachers
and education specialists and
i i don't know as i can answer that i
think that would work as well i don't
i don't know in practice if there's any
difference
well so um so follow up on that um
there's there's obviously a difference
because the amendment is introducing
this instructional specialist and you've
defined that there's a difference
between an instructional specialist and
an educational specialist
and um
and i guess you know
my ques a question would be
how is it how's it currently done in
practice right now with these nine
members representing classroom teachers
or
education specialists reading from the
existing language
so
individuals holding certificate
credentials in one of those areas apply
to be on the professional standards
board and the state board of education
vets those applications and uh votes on
those applications to appoint or not to
appoint to the professional standards
board all right so follow up on that
um
you're using the on line nine it says
nine members representing and so i i
interpreted that as maybe even somebody
like like mr hawkins who who represents
um i forget the number
you know
fifteen thousand teachers from from from
across the state he technically is a
representative of of
of classroom teachers
so could somebody like like mr hawkins
be a member of the board or is it as
you've
talked about um
somebody that actually holds a uh
a um
a license in those fields
so yeah that's a good question um
strictly reading this i i would say yes
uh past practice that has not been the
case okay
so final question would in in order to
to
line up with past practice and
potentially the
the original legislative intent
of this
would it would it you know if we got to
work on this anyway
um would it make sense to change the
word from representing
to maybe something like comprised of or
consisting of and then if there actually
have to be licensed put licensed
classroom teachers
um
licensed educational specialists and
licensed instructional specialists just
to be very clear i think that would
certainly make it very clear okay thank
you and do they have to be employed can
they're licensed
well we have many retired folks who
maintain a license we have many
unemployed folks who maintain a license
so
they could be retired and
so you have a license
i could be a member you could we would
welcome that even though i'm not
employed
yes
i get a hundred dollars a year
not on the psp
representative nelson
thank you mr chairman thank you
do they have to be a resident of new
hampshire or could somebody from
massachusetts
be one of these folks
or vermont
they they could be from out of state yes
excuse me if they hold a new hampshire
license and we have many individuals
from our surrounding states but they
have to hold a new hampshire license
okay
representative tanner
thank you again just looking at the
website the doe website
the teachers and educational specialist
group
is consisted of an out of district
coordinator
a school counselor
a special education coordinator
a special educator an english teacher
and a coordinator for public education
and school support from nea new
hampshire
i am concerned that you don't have
classroom teachers there
i am it's a real concern of mine and i'm
massage that particular
nine members
uh since we're already adding
instructional specialists to that to
make sure that the
representation or
uh
comprised of
has uh an adequate amount of of
licensed classroom teachers
uh yep thank you um
i share your concern but i can tell you
as a practical matter the hardest
category for us to recruit members to
the psb is from classroom teachers
because
uh typically for them to attend a
meeting it entails them
uh their their principle replacing them
for the day in their classroom every
month
and we've heard that that is a real
block to many teachers wanting to serve
on the professional standards board
because a substitute teacher has to be
brought in to replace them for the day
yes go ahead
is there any possibility to move the
meeting time so it doesn't require
during the day or
then we run into a problem with the cbas
talk to the retired teachers association
okay are there further questions
not seen thank you very much thank you
are there any other people who like to
speak on on this bill
i
uh thank you very much i think most of
the committee is is back
um and we have before us to start things
off this afternoon house exhibit senate
bill 386
relative to the determination of state
adequate
education grants and chartered public
school tuition amounts
and i will call on the prime sponsor
senator hennessey thank you mr chairman
and members of the house education
committee i am erin hennessey i
represent senate district one which is
the northern half grafton and all of
coast county
and we do still have snow in some areas
i am here to introduce senate bill 386
which was a request of the department of
education and does some technical fixes
and i will defer any questions to the
department
thank you
thank you that was the uh
most succinct uh testimony we've had
today
i see no questions on that testimony so
i will call on our next guest
now it's on okay it's red
good afternoon um we asked over the
summer a group of legislators to
submit this bill on behalf of the
department of education
because it's been a long-standing issue
for the department in 2013 the
department of education had an audit
from the lba relative to the adequate
education funding formula and they
identified a few errors or issues that
they found in the law that made the law
either confusing to implement or were
relatively unclear we at that time had
legislation proposed
to uh amend the law and unfortunately
that proposed legislation did not go
through
we propose it again maybe in 2016 or 17
i forget which year and then again last
year we tried to attach it to a
different funding bill
and that different funding bill ended up
being itled so as a result of that the
amendment that we had tried to get
through did not go through so here we
are almost 10 years later
still trying to get through some
legislation mostly clarifying and adding
the word the or amounts and things like
that as a result of this lba audit
the most important thing for the
committee to understand relative to this
bill is it does not change the
calculation of the formula at all and
this is probably the only time i've ever
seen a bill that has changes to that the
section of the law around the funding
formula that does not have a fiscal note
and we tried to work very hard on this
to make sure it didn't have a fiscal
note
because we wanted to make sure that this
would finally hopefully get through for
on behalf of the department so we could
feel like we had complied with this
outstanding or long-standing lba audit
so i will take any questions from the
committee
any questions uh representative baum
on on
page um three
for on uh line 15
or that section b for the purpose of
calculating it's um shall count as an
additional 0.15 pupil and they're taking
the course now if they're taking
multiple courses is that 0.15 per cost
yes per course i also want to point out
that the way that the law works right
now is a school district only receives
adequate education funding for home
school kids taking courses if there's
excess appropriation in the state budget
this book law was changed in maybe 2015
to include this language
however we've only paid home school
funding to school districts probably
three times in that time period
because those were the years that had
excess funding in the budget
for homes in the adequacy formula but
this does not change the way that the
formula is calculated at all okay thank
you
representative waltz
thank you so i'm the sub the newbie on
this committee so i don't know
everything everybody else does but what
is the definition of a chartered public
school
so a chartered public school is a
school that has been authorized by the
either the state board of education
or a local school district to operate a
chartered public school there are
some
laws that require or that define what a
charter school is and the various
different
different things that a school must do
to operate in compliance with the law
many of those many of those charter
schools in new hampshire are operated by
an independent
organization a non-profit usually or
actually not usually always because it's
required in law for it to be a
non-profit
and they
are funded by the state of new hampshire
there's no tuition that are charged to
any schools or sorry to any parents that
are new hampshire residents for children
participating in those chart those
charter public schools it's actually
very common
confusion that charter schools charge
tuition but they do not for
participation for new hampshire resident
children
so
i'm probably misreading this but i'm
looking at page
one i guess it is
uh line five and six
and it looks to me like you're expanding
you're expanding funding of kindergarten
to chartered schools in a way that's not
currently there
am i misreading that so the current law
for chartered public schools actually
reaches back to
the
the traditional adequacy funding formula
and then there is um this section that
was not updated when the chart when full
day kindergarten went through
we have asked at the department several
times if the charter school
are eligible for full-day kindergarten
funding it was determined that this was
um
always to include charter schools but
this this right here was just not
updated in that section of the law
so that was that is the ongoing
interpretation of that so do do
kindergarteners in a charter school
currently receive this funding yes the
department has been paying full-day
kindergarten funding for all
public school kids that were that attend
full-day kindergarten the department has
been funding them at the full day
okay so there's so we we're not changing
the funding anywhere in any way anywhere
in this bill exactly
okay thank you
versus ellison
thank you mr chairman thank you caitlin
for taking my question on page three
uh lines 13 and 14
uh it it talks about a charter
conversion school yes
was this language involved included in
all previous requests
for
under this or just a new
part of the request the charter school
conversion law currently exists um we
are just updating the words amounts and
annual amounts and what not in there
there are there is a other legislation
that is making its way through i believe
the house or the senate to change the
way that charter conversion schools work
but that is not reflected in this bill
so this does not change conversion
any further
questions
um representative hopson
thank you uh thank you for taking my
question uh you had submitted a um a
formula sheet from the lba for uh at at
the beginning of my term on education
yes um and i understand that there's one
for charter schools as well i was
wondering if you could forward that of
any further questions uh
representative vegas
thank you
i'm just curious about the admr and
why where and what for i just
sure um so the formula right now is
calculated by admr um the formula the
way it works is we look at the number of
kids and so admr stands for average
daily membership and residence as
opposed to average daily membership and
attendance that's adma
and the thing that is confusing that i
want to point out to the committee is
that even though for adma the average
daily membership in attendance uses the
word attendance it has nothing to do
with the amount of time a child is
either absent or attending school so the
formula is not modified for a child
being absent 10 days of a year so we we
do not change the funding formula for
that
right now the formula uses the word adm
a
however then it goes on to talk about
calculating the kids in a resident town
and the way that the formula works we
also then net any statewide education
property tax swept amount against
adequate education grants before we pay
the grants and we do actually make the
payment to the school district where the
child is attending however
because of that swept piece and the we
uh we need to go back to the residential
um side of the formula that's why we
need to do the initial calculation by
admr and then make the payment in line
with adma
so this is how the department has been
paying the formula or calculating the
formula for
14 ish years now but
it's just kind of one of those things
where the math on the paper doesn't work
anything further
we've seen
nothing thank you very much and now you
so we'll close the hearing on house bill
excuse me senate bill 386
and we have about 15 minutes until our
the clock on the wall says 1 30 or
there abouts
so
it is time for
senate bill 410
relative to the public comment periods
at school board meetings and the
meetings of the state board of education
and will that i'll call on the prime
sponsor
good afternoon mr chairman and good
after
afternoon members of the house education
committee for the record my name is
sharon carson and i have the pleasure of
representing senate district 14
comprising the towns of londonderry
hudson in auburn and i have this
afternoon for your consideration
senate bill 410 which is relative to the
public comment periods at school
district meetings and the meetings of
the state board of education
this bill
has been changed from what i had
originally filed and i think as all of
you probably know that tends to happen
during the legislative process
but the one part that was extremely
important to me was the part dealing
with
comment periods at school district
meetings
one of the things that we saw happening
uh this summer and i saw it in my own
district
um and that i really really became very
concerned about was the fact that
parents were not allowed to speak at
these public meetings of our school
board
and quite frankly i think if they had
been allowed to speak to voice their
concerns to the school board
all the ensuing drama would not have
happened
and so
i had been asked by a group of parents
to attend school at the uh our school
board meetings and i went to a couple
and i was really really surprised at
how dismissive the school board was
towards the parents
um i even witnessed a a a
school board member try to use 91a to
stop a parent from speaking
and i i became very very concerned at
that point because i knew it was a
misuse of the law
my other hat i wear i chair senate
judiciary and we tend to get all the 91a
bills so i'm pretty familiar with what
91a is and how it works
but
there just seemed to be a huge
disconnect
between the school board members and the
parents and i tried to remind them that
they're not there to represent the
interest of the school
their job is to represent the parents
and how can you do that if you're not
even listening to the parents or even
giving them an opportunity to speak so
that's why the legislation was filed
um
i think that we've we've learned a
couple of lessons from uh all the covid
procedures and policies that we've gone
through
and i think it's really great that
parents are really starting to pay
attention to what is going on in their
schools what are their children being
taught
and we've got to try to strike a balance
because we can't in many ways stand in
the way of teachers and them doing their
job as well
so what i see this board what this bill
doing is really saying that they shall
provide the opportunity for the public
to comment
and that it shall not be less than 30
minutes they can request that someone
register in advance but not require
pre-registration as a condition of
speaking because one of the things i
found out was that some school boards
say you have to sign up a few days ahead
of time and you have to tell them what
you want to speak about
i don't feel that that's appropriate
i feel that any parent any any taxpayer
in the community has the right to
address the school board over any issue
that they feel is appropriate
that's why you have these public
meetings
some other things happened in in my
community
subcommittees were put together without
public notice
they were getting advice from this
subcommittee about covid protocols and
nobody knew who these people were
because they weren't even meeting in
public
so it just got uglier and uglier and
uglier and i really believe that if
they had a dialogue
that maybe a lot of this could have not
would not have happened but you've got
to give the parents and the taxpayers
the opportunity to address the school
board
i think we all know sometimes people say
things we don't like
but that's part of the job we're here to
listen just as they're here to listen to
the people so
um
there's again it goes on to say that
nothing in this section so restricts
school board from establishing other
reasonable standards for the common
public comment period
provided that such standards are imposed
equally on all speakers
so um that is the part that i can speak
to again the bill was changed i had two
other sections to the original bill
one dealt with school charters we do
have a few school districts that are
governed by charter and it doesn't there
doesn't seem to be a way
for
um the charter to change and i speak to
the town of londonderry where they the
last time that they really had the
charter open was in the late 1980s
and a lot of the parents were
complaining that why aren't we opening
the charter why aren't we talking about
some of these things
and so
but unfortunately senate education took
that one out and there was a section in
on ethics that would require school
boards to all have a code of ethics
i just think that when everybody knows
what the rules are everybody intends to
play a little better
and so um this is this bill is an
attempt to get
school districts and parents talking to
each other
thank you
thank you senator uh representative
hopson
thank you mr chair and um thank you for
taking my question senator uh so i was
on the school board in my town for about
six years and i'm still not able to
articulate
where the conversation the dialogue that
you mentioned can actually happen i know
that that there is public comment
periods but at what point how would a
parent
or parents or even
audience members actually engage in a
dialogue back and forth when does that
happen and how can how can that happen
thank you for your question it can
happen at every meeting
school districts
school board meetings publish an agenda
and so any member of the public in that
community can look to see what's on the
agenda and they might want to offer a
comment or they might want to offer what
they think
about what they're going to be talking
about so that's really where it starts
is being open and being transparent
letting the parents know what's good
what they're going to be talking about
so if a parent chooses to they can
attend that meeting and by requiring
them to have at least 30 minutes
where they can
where the public can address them that's
follow
thank you
so specifically
i think sometimes parents would like to
get an answer to a question
and we hear that that's a meeting in
public versus a public meeting or or a
non-meeting
how do we get
the responses back is that a special
meeting or a hearing
i know thank you again for the question
uh it's really kind of interesting for
me because if
we've we elect these school board
members they're there to to do a job and
if a member of the public comes to them
and asks a question they should be able
to answer that question
why if you unless you you're asking for
something very specific where they have
to go and look for it that's a different
issue
but they can't say look i don't have
that information i will get back to you
leave your name and your telephone
number your address and we'll get that
information and we'll send it to you
there's no reason why you can't give
information it doesn't doesn't have to
be necessarily at a meeting what it is
is saying the parents have the right to
come here and they have a right to ask
questions i know at our school board
meeting we have both our superintendent
our vice superintendent we have our
finance director and the attorney
between all of them they should be able
to answer a question
thank you representative ellison
thank you mr chair thank you senator for
taking my question uh i generally
support the bit the the bill is written
uh
interested in your comment
or comments on
the 30 minutes i mean i'm just let's
theoretically and this happens in a
number of
school board meetings you set a
30-minute limit and you say there are 10
people and you know ahead of time or at
least 10 people want to speak you give
everybody three minutes
one of the observations i have of the
school board meetings in the last year
is people wanted to speak as long as
they wanted to speak and three minutes
would not be sufficient
uh
it may well have been two hours would
not be sufficient
how do you deal
under this set of circumstances with
that kind of frustration which is i have
a right to talk to the board as long as
i want to talk to the board and you
cannot limit the amount of time that i
have to ask questions or whatever
thank you for the question we're talking
about having an opportunity to speak
it is going to be
the purview of the chair to decide what
those parameters are so if you have
10 people show up they're going to speak
and tell and you tell them right from
the very beginning
we have a lot of people that would like
to speak
i'm going to treat everyone the same
everyone's going to get three minutes
and that's it we do that here when we
get huge public hearings where we have
to go over to uh rep's hall because
we've got so many people and oftentimes
we will put people
on a timer and we'll say we want to get
through everyone we want to hear from
everyone so we're gonna
have a three minute time limit
you can you know please talk to us don't
read whatever if you've got something
that you've written down don't read it
um please try to paraphrase or we will
ask well okay we're going to do the
three minutes please don't repeat what
other people have said
and it works and i mean but i mean again
it's the purview of the chair i don't
want the state micromanaging school
boards either and telling them this this
and this we have 30 minutes
oftentimes you know a chair of a
committee will schedule a public hearing
for
a half an hour and sometimes it might
take 15 minutes sometimes it's two hours
later it's kind of difficult to judge
how long someone is going how many
people are going to show up
and so just 30 minutes gives them an
opportunity for people to come in and
talk if they want to it's up to the
chair to put those parameters around
them
thank you thank you representative boehm
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
carson
um
one of the problems i see with this it
doesn't say when
for example
i know in our school board meeting it's
you can there's a
commit i mean people can talk at the
beginning and at the end and i've known
some school boards and i've seen press
on it only say you can do the couple
public comments at the end of their
meeting which could be midnight
so shouldn't be be
a comment i mean in your legislation
here that at the beginning
at the beginning of the school board
meeting
thank you representative um in the
original language it was 30 minutes at
the beginning of the hearing
um
but again there are some districts that
will allow comment at the end as well
right so
again
we i guess they're trying not to
micromanage and just say
30 minutes and leave it up to the chair
to decide if it's at the beginning or at
the end
but if this committee
chooses to change that then
that's the purview of this committee
yeah because one of the comments that
i've heard from other school boards or
people complaining about them yeah
they'll do the 30 minutes or comments at
the end of the meeting which means
it's going to be midnight you know that
i mean so it's a way of not allowing
comments
question um it says public comment
period shall be no less than 30 minutes
i attended hundreds of school board
meetings and there was no public comment
does that mean they have to set it and
sit and wait 30 minutes
if there's you know if they have to keep
it open as a public comment or if
there's no one there or one comment and
move on
um again it thank you for the question
representative it is saying no less than
30 minutes so it will be a 30 minute
block of time that will be available to
the public should they choose to address
the school board
um
it's
there are there are going to be people
they're going to be time when you're
going to get a lot of people they're
going to be times when nobody shows up
but i truly believe that
that time should be set aside
for the public to come in if if they
representative
waltz i'm on the same line and that is
you know you've got large communities in
your district where you're likely to get
a large turnout
i'm in the same district as
representative holland one of our
communities is only about 2 000 people
and if we have to set aside 30 minutes
and say
one person shows up
do they get to monopolize that 30
minutes does the board have to sit and
listen to them for a full 30 minutes or
can they can we amend this and say 30
minutes unless there's fewer than three
people there so that we're only really
looking at maybe somebody
i mean i could see in a small town
you've got some
maverick who shows up every single week
takes it 30 minutes and monopolizes it
for 30 minutes every single week the
board sits there and listens to them and
nobody else bothers to show up that to
me is almost abusive of the process and
of the board so i'm trying to figure out
how this would work in small communities
thank you for the question um
again i i don't i speak to not
micromanaging and it's going to be the
purview of the chair how to manage that
30 minutes
if they want to allow someone to speak
for 30 minutes
that's their decision
but i would imagine that a lot of school
board
chairs wouldn't allow something like
that and would put some sort of
parameter around it so you don't have
one person
dominating the whole process but again i
don't i don't see a way how we can
um
do something like that because you might
have someone who's you know i want to go
to the school board meeting tonight i
want to get up there and i want to talk
about this particular issue i'm on my
way home from work i'm running late i
got you know if they're gonna shut it
off say at 7 30 and i walk in the door
at 7 25 and find out well we didn't we
had one person here and they spoke and
that was it your opportunity to speak is
now gone so by leaving it open and
letting the chair decide how they want
to manage that time i think is the
appropriate way to go
representative porter
i'm sorry follow-up
you know
it's pretty hard as it is to get people
to volunteer for these spots and we've
had a lot of elections in our
communities that were unopposed because
you can barely get enough people to run
if you're expecting school board members
to basically have to sit there an extra
half hour even if nobody's showing up
don't you think that's going to even
make it harder to convince people that
want to serve on boards these days when
these meetings are automatically a half
hour longer even if nobody shows up to
testify
thank you representative
these are also elected officials
they ran for office nobody forced
anybody to do anything
they
chose to run for office
and i think every single person in this
room knows that there are times where it
is difficult serving the people
because of the time demands on all of us
but we know what we sign up for
and part of our job and a big part of
our job is to listen to the people to
listen to our constituents the people
that put us here
and quite frankly if you don't have 30
minutes to listen to people maybe some
people should really rethink whether or
not they should be in be running for
office we need dedicated individuals and
i don't care what party they belong to
because school boards are non-partisan
who care about our kids and who want to
work with parents
to better their children's education and
if they can't spare an extra 30 minutes
of their time then maybe they should
think about running for something else
representative porter
thank you mr chair thank you senator um
so
i also have served on the school board
we always had a
public comment section at the beginning
of the meeting a public comment section
at the end of the meeting and we limited
it to five minutes per person so
sometimes we could be there for quite a
long time if it was a long
large number of people and sometimes
there was nobody to speak at all
would you consider or would you be
amenable to some sort of language in
this bill that allows the school board
to continue with its business
if there's no public comment um no one
available for public comment
and then if someone shows up they could
allow that public comment because to be
honest there were meetings when we were
done in 45 minutes i mean we and
yes we are elected officials but we are
volunteers
and it's hard to find those volunteers
so this
it just seems like it would it's a
little bit too you have to sit there for
30 minutes even though there's no one
that wants to speak to you
um because somebody might show up
at you know at the end of the time that
wants to speak to you
seems to put
to not be a fish efficient use of
somebody's precious evening
time that they have so i'm just
wondering if you'd be amenable to some
kind of language that would allow for
flexibility with the board if no one is
there to speak
thank you representative quite frankly
this bill is in the hands of this
committee
and this committee is going to amend it
however they see fit
i i i'm one of those folks that i filed
the legislation but once it gets filed
and assigned to a committee
this i'm the sponsor of it but it
belongs to the committee so you folks
today are going to hear the le here
uh the testimony you're going to
deliberate and you're going to make the
changes that you feel are appropriate
thank you representative luno no good
representation okay representative lakis
thank you
um i notice it
it talks about public comment period and
at our school board meeting
i heard parents go in to ask questions
of the school board and they were told
this is a public comment time you can
make comments we're not here to answer
your questions
representative thank you for that
question because i heard the same thing
too
and again this is
i don't believe that there's going to be
an easy answer to this because you're
dealing with the makeup of boards and
the personality of the individuals that
are serving on these boards
and i i strongly believe myself
that
these are elected individuals
they they are there to represent the
people that means listening to the
people engaging with the people if the
people have a question
that question needs to get answered
and if it gets answered during a public
comment
session great
if they have a mechanism that you can
submit questions online to the school
board and we'll answer your questions
that's great too but i just don't want
to micromanage this whole process but i
realized this is a problem it's a
problem that got revealed during covid
because of kids not physically being in
school parents were home they were
watching what their kids were doing and
they started to get upset at what they
were seeing and they wanted to engage
with their school board that is a local
elected body
and they found way too many impediments
in order to do that
and so many parents have stayed very
engaged you're talking about their
children in their children's future
and they're very very concerned about
that
so
you've got to try to balance that
against people who volunteer
[Music]
and then getting the business done and
listening to the people
i think we all know that's not really an
easy balance but we figure it out and i
think that they'll be able to figure it
out as well
president moffatt
thank you mr and thank you senator for
being here and as representative ellis
said i think i understand the intent and
and
also generally supportive
leading to my question i'll point out
that the bill before this one had a half
hour block scheduled for it we only use
15 minutes and
and i agree uh that a
a good chair can manage that time and
i'm i'm not particularly worried about
scenarios about you know who might show
up or who might it's something as you
said the chair could manage my question
it has to do with what constitutes the
public
uh i think i i think that many of us are
kind of assuming that those are the town
folk and the citizens of the town but
sometimes educators who work at the
school live outside the town limits some
uh stakeholders don't live in the within
the town and my question is what if
there are some uh
activists or
non-residents
who are they part of the public can they
come in and can they have some of this
time
thank you very much for your question um
again i see this as a management done by
the chair
that you would have individuals from
your community
that
if they wanted to speak that they very
well could speak and it would be up to
the chair whether or not they wanted to
allow people who are activists from
other communities to speak again it's
their time and they need to micro that
we don't need to micromanage their time
they get to manage their time if they
wish to allow people from who do not
live in their community to speak
that's going to be up to the chair
thank you
representative litchfield
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
thank you so much for bringing forth
this bill
i had sat on two school boards during
all of covid and it and it was rough and
i think part of why the people were so
angry was because they weren't being
heard for so long
i understand the bill is in our hands
now but i want to ask you and respect
you and your wishes as a sponsor
i'm wondering if we if we consider
changing the verbiage of public comment
to
even public exchange or something but we
go through a list of synonyms of
something that may be a little bit more
appropriate than public comment
and i i
understand where you're coming from with
a specific amount of time i completely
get that but i am i do think there are
times when we would sit there doing
nothing i'm wondering um
if we did just put back public exchange
at the beginning and the end of the
meeting but without a time limit
representative as i've as i've said the
bill is now in your hands and your
committee is going to do with the bill
good afternoon mr chairman are there any
thank you for taking my question senator
i see both sides of this i wouldn't want
to sit there for 30 minutes is there
some way of warding this so that there's
a 30 minutes slot say from 7 to 7 30
people can come and talk but if they're
not there you can conduct regular
business i don't know how you'd word
that
and all of a sudden you're 10 minutes
into the meeting
they would be able to talk if there's
nobody there you can run the meeting and
at 7 30
you're too late
thank you very much for your question
um
representative nelson i have every
confidence in your chair who is well
known as being a wonderful wordsmith to
try and figure out how to get that done
go downstairs and tell senator ward that
[Laughter]
you're off the hook i'm off the hook see
thank you very much thank you very much
i understand this whole 30 minutes
because we in the senate we usually
schedule our meetings 15 minutes apart
and sometimes they're like it's an hour
maybe two hours later you know we run
behind and look i get it but a chair
knows how to manage that time so again
thank you all very much this afternoon
it's a pleasure to be back and house
education senate uh ed does it in 10
minutes for each bill
well they try
well there's a reason why senator ward
yeah what we're going to do because
representative cordelli has to go
downstairs to testify down there with
sena i'm going to have him testify next
and then we'll go to
how come you put down 30 minutes on your
part of that is explained in my
amendment
you're mike
i would think i would know
um glenn cordelli representing
tuftonboro moultonborough and sandwiched
in the beautiful lakes region
and um i agree with
a lot of what senator carson had just
said
in looking at the legislation
this weekend
i had a
amendment drafted which is being passed
around now
um i think it
does address some of the comments um and
questions we just heard
um
and i'll
on second or third line
of the bill
it removes
the
language that a public comment period
shall be heard for no less than 30
minutes
and instead
says
the public comment periods shall be
provided for public input for agenda
items before board action is taken and
shall also be provided for non-agenda
items of community interest
each public comment period shall be for
no less than 30 minutes unless comments
are completed earlier
which i think hopefully addresses the
30-minute requirement
but also i think it's very very
important
that the public has the ability to
comment on
agenda items before the board takes
action very often we've seen
um
with comment periods at the end of the
meeting
someone might want to speak on something
that the board is discussing or voting
on and because the comment period is the
end of the meeting the board has already
taken action without any input from the
public
so that was one of the main things i
wanted to address
in this uh amendment
and in addition um it removes uh section
two
of the bill as presented to us
involving the state board of education
public comment period
i'll leave that to the
state board of education
and i see the chairman is here um uh
and will be testifying um but i've seen
many um
state board meeting where they've gone
on for a considerable length of time
with public comment
probably for
longer than they would have uh planned
or liked
the same as we do
so i i think that this bill should focus
on local school boards and public
comment periods and allowing the public
to provide input
and not
be prohibited from commenting on things
that might be interest
of interest to them
and to the community thus the both the
agenda items and non-agenda items uh
provided for in the amendment
and with that i i thank you thank you
very much are there questions questions
go ahead
i don't want to hold you up thank you
thank you
my question just quickly is with both
what the senator presented and what you
presented
why is it that um school boards may
request persons register in advance of
the meeting
what would be the purpose or what would
that accomplish
um
i i did not strike that from the bill um
but uh i um
personally would not be in in favor of
requiring pre-registration
i i personally would
that it may school boards may request
that person's register advance to the
meeting i don't even not even
comfortable with that if you if you were
the committee wanted to strike that i i
would have no
objection for the comments yes
representative cornell
do you think signing register before the
meeting can just mean signing up before
the meeting starts so that they can call
people in the order in which they signed
up so that if they got there early and
signed up they could go first rather
than
wait till so that it's not random it's
just sure because i think manchester
does they just
sign up as they get there so that they
have the order to call them in sort of
like we do with our pink cards
further questions from the committee
thank you very much
thank you mr chairman
my name is representative tom dolan i am
the
chair of the municipal and county
committee in the house
and i've just finished
seven terms as the
town councilor in londonderry so
last month was my last time on the
committee
so uh
the bill that i wrote
is not in front of you so i apologize
for that but i just want to talk to you
about the spirit of it and what you
might
be able to do with it i wrote uh house
bill 1195
which was very short
and uh to the point
uh and it was in response to what i was
observing and and
members of the uh
of the various boards we're observing is
that across our communities
the unevenness of public comment
and uh how it's being
run
uh in some some cases there were towns
or communities that didn't allow any
public comment or or
uh
in the school board
scenario they'd show up
and the response they would get i'm
sorry you're not on the agenda you're
not going to get any public comment
and
then there are
some communities that i'll say
use a little mischief with public
comment and what do i mean by that there
are communities that
will
state they're going to have public
comment but they'll hold that public
comment until uh
maybe 10 or 11 o'clock at night
and i asked and i even queried about
what you know why are you holding public
comments so late well
maybe these folks were going to go home
and then we'll be done with it
so to me that's that's being mischievous
and that's not the spirit of being open
to the public and and get
getting that comment that can can help
run a better government
so my my bill was much less specific
than what you have in front of you
and it basically said if you're going to
run a public meeting
you had to have a period of public
comment
and there were some things about how
long and all that stuff and that can be
worked out but that's basically it
because if you if this passes great i
like what senator carson wrote you're
going to hear from the
from the department of uh
education
school board
association i'm sorry uh soon which i
like what what they've put out because
they talk about
privacy rules around
students information and so forth and
that's important i didn't include that
in my bill but that's important
but
the the issue that that i'm working is
broadly across all
public boards
in the municipality
why should this only affect school
boards what about the planning board
what about the conservation commission
why should they not have public comment
an area of
development in an area that includes
wetlands when you want and if you're
close to those wetlands wetlands and you
want to come forth and give some comment
about that
you'd want to do that probably at a
conservation
committee meeting
but if there's no public comment then
you might not get in to get in
you may not be able to speak
so uh my suggestion is for the committee
is to consider what you have in front of
you
consider uh hb 1195 as well and perhaps
put together a uh i i'm admits to saying
a study commission but put together a
group maybe a committee of conference
that could
take a look at all these different
inputs that you've got and uh come up
with with something that works for
everybody
i think that's the appropriate way i
think that just focusing on school
boards
does
address the issue that's been in the
news this past six months about crt and
about
school boards not not addressing it i
mean that that's
going to go away uh eventually
i'm talking about how do we run the
state how do we run our public meetings
and uh
and you don't want to get done with this
and the
folks at home say that's great we got
the school board squared away now let's
take let's take all these other meetings
one at a time and there's only 19 of
them so we can have 19 bills that will
affect all of them
so so i would suggest you you broaden
your scope
and include all those other public
meetings where public comment is so
important for the dialogue between our
elected officials and the public to get
that dialogue completed and
in place
any questions
thank you very much representative boom
chairman and thank you chairman
and i had the member of the town council
in londonderry did you have a comment
period before and after or at any time
yeah council meetings thank you
representative uh
the uh the comment question we had for
the town council
was uh typically
15 minutes
and it started right at the beginning of
the meeting
and the chairman would ask for public
comment
and if there was public comment he would
manage it whether it be the next 15
minutes or the next 30 minutes it would
be up to him to manage that and if there
was no public comment because that
that's come up excuse me that's come up
here what do we do with those extra 30
minutes if there was no public comment
uh in addition to that he would close
public comment it wouldn't make people
sit there and look at their watch he
would close it so there's a way to
manage that and and at the school board
because this happens to talk a lot about
school boards the school board didn't
always have public comment they're
having it now mainly because we've
kind of escalated in the town uh
dialogue about how important it is but
further questions
nazi any thank you very much thank you
thank you chairman ladd good members of
the mc of the committee uh barrett
christina new hampshire school boards
association um we are uh in support of
senate bill 410 i'll give you a little
bit of the background as to as to how we
got they got here
um so initially um house bill 1195 was
heard across the hall um in senator
excuse me in house judiciary um i
haven't gone back and looked at my notes
i don't know if nhsba took a position on
the bill as introduced
um but um uh
the house judiciary um made an amendment
i believe it was offered by um chairman
gordon
which is the the iteration of house bill
1195 um that the committee is hearing
right now
um uh and which i just passed around um
uh is so you have to so you can compare
and contrast house bill um 1195 and i'll
get to 410 in a minute so that passed
out of um uh house judiciary passed the
full house that was just heard in
senate ed at one o'clock
in the meantime
senator carson introduced senate bill
410 and i have it here as introduced
every public comment meeting by hell
every public every public meeting held
by a school board shall include a period
for public comment which shall be
publicly noticed and shall comply with
rsa
91a period of public comments shall be
30 minutes of length and shall be held
at the beginning of the meeting of the
first order of business some other
language in there and then it also
included a school board code of ethics i
think we've had a couple bills this
session that have spoken about a school
board
code of ethics
so nhsba opposed senate bill 410. um i
know how this works though and i know
that um with um
1195 crossing over
into the the senate and it being
senator carson's um bill 410 i know
shares have some influence over their
committees and perhaps some influence
over the legislation that's before them
so um i fully anticipated and that
we would have a bill we meaning the
legislature would adopt a bill relative
to public comments at school board
meetings so with that in mind um the
version of senate bill 410 that you see
before you is nhsba's language i drafted
it we had a good conversation in um in
senate ed and this is this is what came
out um to a couple of the comments um uh
to the questions that were raised
um um
you know
30 minutes i mean you know i don't know
i guess the bigger question is we've had
some questions or comments about should
that be held at the beginning of the of
the meeting i would nhsb would not
object to that we can pull language from
410 as introduced
it says the period for public comment
shall be a minimum of 30 minutes in
length and shall be held at the
beginning of the meeting as the first
order of business there'd be no
objection if we put that language back
in
um
uh
the questions about you know if nobody
shows up
and you know what do you do does the
board have to sit there and and and wait
for the 30 minutes i don't know um you
know representative nelson you said i
don't know how we put that language in
law i don't either i don't know how you
could
craft something reasonable that made
sense um i would hope at that point you
know maybe
some common sense would take over and if
you're
15 minutes into the meeting and somebody
ran late for whatever reason weren't
kids this that or the other thing you
know presuming there aren't a hundred
people lined up you know if you could
get the chair's attention and say mr
chair madam chair i came late would it
be possible if i spoke for three minutes
on on you know this issue or or whatnot
um
so you know i hope that would leave some
of the concerns if we just said at least
we're going to put it in the in the
uh we had a question a representative
moffett i believe it was you
um that said about non-residents are
they allowed to speak um i
i i'm aware of i think at least one
school board in new hampshire
that
i don't know if they disallow
non-residents but they give preference
to
residents and or people who have a
direct interest in the school district
the teacher may live out of the
community
they've crafted i haven't i know they
were working on it i have to go back and
see what that board may have enacted um
you know i've done a little bit of
research on the first amendment
parameters of that and yes you are
allowed to um exclude non-residents and
i'll be honest with you
so some of many of the disruptions that
we saw at school board meetings last
summer and last fall they were from
people who did not live in that
community didn't have kids that went to
school in that community crafting that
sort of policy is a little challenge
because it's not just the non-residents
you have to be mindful of um with our
communities that do tuition agreements
right so you know
it can be done but it could be a
challenge but you know you're obviously
going to want to let those parents
parents speak even though they may not
be residents
um representative litchfield about the
exchange and representative hodgson
about the communications and dialogue
between the board um and members of the
public
you know in exchange could a board do
that possibly but
that 30 minutes is going to turn into
three hours real quick you know my my my
simple answer is you know if you have a
question and it's not being answered at
the meeting call your superintendent or
your board chair the next day if you
want to have a dialogue
you know where people can just come and
speak if you will you know nhsb was
recommending when boards were
considering the masking issue last
summer don't put that on your regular
school board meeting maybe have two
hours tonight we're only talking about
masks tonight we're only talking about
our our return to school plan it's an
extra meeting it is what it is but you
know if we're getting if we're going to
start engaging in a dialogue back and
forth or an exchange
the the 30 i mean if you're limited to
three or five minutes per person that's
going to be gone before you know it you
know and then you're only allowing six
people to talk if it's limited to 30
minutes that would be though be some of
my concerns with with that um i have not
seen representative cordelie's amendment
um it removes the 30 minutes
um public input for agenda items and
non-agenda items i think if we maybe did
language that said the 30 minutes is at
the beginning of the meeting that may
alleviate some of those concerns but i
mean if you wanted to do some boards do
do a second one you know first one
agenda items the back side you know
either what's on your mind or a recap of
what we discussed at that meeting again
i haven't seen the amendment
um
representative lichfield you asked about
the pre-registration language and why is
that in there
senator carson's bill
as introduced not the current version of
410 it says the school board shall not
require people who want to speak during
the public comment period to register or
sign in more than two hours in advance
of the meeting the school board may give
preference
in speaking to parents of children in
the district or other persons who live
in the district so
wanting to try and address senator
carson's language in the original bill
that's why that language now exists in
in the version before you that's what
that's that's the genesis of that
um so you know i i i did then last i
mean to to to to representative dolan's
you know comments i think one of one of
the other bills that we had in this
committee this session i forget what one
i think talked about a public comment
period for for school boards and i said
look if you're going to put that in the
right to know law it's got to apply to
every public body town council city
council
village districts the water commission
so on and so forth
i think that's a different issue
altogether
but again so you know seeing the writing
on the wall and recognizing that we were
probably going to get something about
school board meeting uh public public
comments at school board meetings nhsba
worked with senate education the
language that you see before you is
language i drafted if there's room for
amendments or you would like an
amendment
let me know i'm happy to happy to work
with the committee to to smooth it out
but i think
i think by and large as as written i
hopefully alleviate some of the concerns
that we heard both in this committee and
in senate education as well and um i'm
happy to answer any questions
thank you very much barrett uh
representative boehm
thank you mr chairman and i think you
take my question wouldn't you agree that
as a former member of the school board
sometimes questions can't be answered
and should be referred to maybe another
agenda item
and
so we agree
thank you very much uh representative
yeah so you know at some point you know
sometimes the question may not the
answer may not be available right then
and there you know i tell boards and we
don't put this in a policy or anything
but we tell boards and superintendents
you know if you have the answer
available
you know it's somebody's talking about
you know uh uh
somebody's talking about the leaky roof
or the new ball field or whatever and
the guy and the person making public
comments says
what was our budget last year with the
ba and the superintendent of the board
chair it was 20 million dollars so just
answer the question you know you don't
need to but you know if it's substantive
you know about well how is this
curriculum chosen and how often do you
review your curriculum what
considerations go into selecting your
curriculum and your textbooks well that
may have to that may have to be a phone
call in a conversation between
the the inquirer and and either the
board chair the superintendent or the
principal or whatnot so trying to craft
into a law how you do that it's so
specific based on the question that's
being asked
thank you
thank you uh yes represent ellison thank
you mr share thank you barry for taking
my question
i
don't want to get too far down into the
weeds on this but this is one where we
need to be specific uh
in terms of a meeting is laid out in the
in the amendment there would be the
public comment period before the meeting
we've got
you you've got something here which says
not less than one hour i'm trying to
figure out what the board chair does
when yeah i mean 100 people come in and
in the board shares trying to figure out
how many of you want to speak right and
do i then or does the board say well
there's a whole lot there aren't many
we'll do 45 minutes we'll do 20 minutes
we'll do an hour we'll give people three
minutes we'll give people five minutes
that will end up being the purview of
the chair basically in your mind thank
you for the question representative it's
typically a board policy
um some policies can give the board
share flexibility relative to that
but and hsba would advise the board to
have a public comment policy i mean for
no other reason it spells out the rules
of engagement for the public and and we
tell people if you know you're going to
have a lot of people showing up at a
meeting you know and about a lot it's
often you know more than five right we
say print off a copy of your policy and
put it on every chair or put it on a
table so people can grab it so they're
not surprised when they're cut off at
three minutes or they're not surprised
when they're talking about something
that may or may not necessarily be on
the agenda or or whatnot um so
we think it's best done by school board
policy rather than it coming back on the
specific chair the specific person
making making the rules on the fly it
gives every the public a clear
expectation of what the rules are
thank you
thank you mr chair and uh thank you mr
christina i'm not trying to belabor this
i'm really just looking for
an actual uh process
so um parents have explained to me that
it's very frustrating for them to to go
to a meeting
looking for answers and all that's
available is public comment
so that does not require anyone to
answer them what my specific question is
and i know that oftentimes some things
aren't available right away or
inappropriate to talk about in public
what is the process for getting a back
and forth
that it is
is that um i'm not trying to be
disrespectful
i just really don't know sure thank you
so i mean
thank you for the question
representative does the person want to
back and forth with the board or does
the person want a back and forth with
somebody that can answer some of their
questions
because that's going to depend on who
you contact um you know
i mean call the board share and see if
you can have a conversation with him or
her call the superintendent and see if
her
um
excuse me
you know
if if one individual wants to have a
dialogue with the full board
you know i i just
there's there's got to be an expediency
and efficiency aspect to this as well
too
talking about and complaining about
board meetings running until 11 or 12
o'clock at night well if you're doing a
second public comment period at the end
of your meeting you can't do two hours
of back and forth in public comment
conversation at the beginning of the
meeting so i mean there's a first
amendment principle
called other avenues of communication
you can limit speech here
but you have to leave open other avenues
of communication those other avenues of
communication are a phone call an email
whatever it may be so i mean
and i'm not trying to be vague
representative i hope you understand
that as well too
um but you know if we if we get into a
dialogue
it
that 30 minutes is going to run into two
hours and the back end public comments
is going to be at midnight so i don't i
mine seems to be
it's usually that one right between
no it's on
well we'll have to call him up in conway
and
okay uh barrett was
uh taking questions are there any more
questions of the yes representative
cornell
from
thank you for taking my question um
rough cordelli's amendment seems to take
out um the comment period for the state
board of education
and is that something that you had put
in as or worked with senator carson or
something that's important to do sure
thanks thank you very much um
i know mr klein is here and i certainly
won't be speaking for him in the state
board but um the last typical public
comment period with typical in-person
people coming sign up two minutes three
minutes whatever um was march 2020 we
all know what happened then
um then there was written public comment
only listed on the agendas from april
2020 to june 2021
and there's been no public comment
listed on any of the agendas for the
state board from july 2021 to the
present now i understand they have some
facility issues um that not my place to
speak about mr klein can do that um
but
you know it seems to be that if local
school boards are going to be obligated
to have a public comment period the
example should be set from our leaders
do you have a question represented
litchfield thank you and thank you for
if if i can get out something super long
in one breath it will count as one
question right hopefully
um okay you have three minutes to state
your question
i can talk fast um so what
what i my experience has been in the
past regarding public comment
and and the frustration with the public
is both let's say the principal the
superintendent any employees uh that are
up
at the table um if there's a simple
question that is requested of them
they give the blank stare right and then
the public gets really frustrated and i
think things escalate from there
um
and i've been told that they're not to
answer unless the board chair instructs
them to answer or i've even had them
look at me and say like i don't have to
answer i'm not supposed to answer handle
it sort of thing just curious
i don't want to get into the weeds but
it and i'll give you a simple example um
you know you talk about the answers that
could be done very quickly you know sau
16 are a deliberative session at least
this year if not several years in a row
people have requested the population in
the middle of high school and they're
not given it they've requested the
unreserved fund balance and they're not
given it and i feel like i know we're
getting into the weeds and there's local
and the question is would i agree right
no no my question is what no my question
is how does it work as far as people
answering questions not in the policy
right
thank you for the question
representative relative to employees i
mean it's a board meeting the employees
work for the superintendent i would
think that the employee should you know
the chair and the superintendent should
ascertain
whether or not the employees are going
to speak and you know i i can't i can't
answer for every question that may have
been asked but not answered at a local
school board
um
you know and i i don't want to throw
anybody under the bus either but you
know if you have what's the popular i
mean if you can answer the question
right there without requiring any
research it would be
the reasonable thing to do is provide
the information
representative are you done with your
questions
do you want to follow up
would you believe that sau 16 does have
resident only policies for a public
comment number one
um and then
yes i did have
i'll save it that thank you thank you i
mean i didn't know that sau had 16 had
that um
i guess doesn't surprise me that was not
the district or the sou i was speaking
about when i gave my example a few
minutes ago though
thank you very much
representative moffat
thank you ms chair thank you for taking
my question to follow up just briefly on
representative hobson's question earlier
in a little bit on representative blitz
fields and i've been on the board so
we're talking a lot about public comment
and then this non-public session so
oftentimes a question will come up
during public comment and the response
will be that's a personal matter or
whatever and we'll take that up in
non-public so my question simply
is and i think you're probably a great
one to ask this are there
and i'm sure this has come up before are
there safeguards in place in terms of
accountability for when a board goes
non-public uh in terms of the trust of
the people because
uh you know folks oh god they're
part of military oh gosh they've gone to
uh non-public and we'll never know so
their safeguards are kind of what are
there mechanisms to reassure people that
that non-public is not being abused sure
thank you for the question
representative um well at the very least
the one when the motion is made to enter
non-public session the motion has to
state the specific paragraph under which
um the the board or the public body is
being used it's rsa 91-a
cone three paragraph two and then
there's a b c d so on and so forth so
the motion on its face has to state
under paragraph a the minutes have to
state under paragraph a
um and then it is the responsibility of
the members of that public body to limit
their discussion and conversation only
to the purpose that was stated in the
motion for going into non-public session
um you know my experience is that most
boards have at least one um right to
know law hawk on them that you know i
don't want to say keeps the other people
in check because the other people are
doing the right thing but the person
that knows the right to know very very
well make sure that the eyes are dotted
the t's are crossed and and i mean to
some degree you know the board members
have to be behaving properly when they
go into non-public session and limit
their conversation to to only the
matters the only the the purpose that
they entered in non-public session don't
talk start talking about a thousand
other things
i mean so the safeguards i mean
you know how do you know what's being
discussed in non-public session i mean
there are non-public session minutes
obviously um that need to be released i
believe it's 72 hours if i'm not
mistaken unless they're sealed um
that issue be the non-public session
minute issue
causes boards a lot of constant and this
is off topic is it okay if i continue
i don't want to say consternation but
there's a balance between not putting
anything in minutes that is going to
reveal the private or confidential
nature for which you entered into
non-public session right
excuse me
if you put the detailed minutes that
discusses the student the staff member
and you know the the confidential and
private reason why you're in non-public
session to begin with you have to seal
the minutes then so they don't become
public
the other way to do that without
stealing minutes is to put the make
non-public session minutes very bland
the board entered non-public sessions
under this paragraph to discuss
a personnel matter
no decisions were made period so that's
gonna you know and there's also a
balance
you know sometimes
sometimes you need the detailed minutes
of the non-public session because if
let's say it's a staff discipline matter
and let's say you get a new
superintendent a year 18 months into the
issue when it's still ongoing and you
get new school board members you may
want to go back and read those minutes
from a year year and a half ago to
refresh your recollection what did the
board say what did the attorney say what
did you you know what did the
superintendent say those have to be
sealed then which frustrates the public
as well too but then if you put them
bland so you're not divulging anything
private or confidential that's
frustrating the public as well too
i don't know where that balance is
because i'm trying to satisfy the
public's right to know while also make
sure school board doesn't get in trouble
for disclosing confidential information
yes
i think it's very helpful so my my quick
follow-up question is in your experience
have there ever been redacted uh
minutes from non-public that have been
issued yeah thank you for the question
um
yes um
the curious thing about redaction is
it's a judicial creation there's nothing
in the right to know law that speaks to
redacting documents the supreme court
made it up
um
that's a whole other issue but yes um
the challenge with redaction is it's
it's timely and costly and i'm not
saying that's not appropriate you know
i'm just saying that
you know you a school board we know we
know what the right to know law so you
can go into non-public session to
discuss these issues and they all relate
to somebody's privacy or confidentiality
that's why you can that's why you can do
it
redacting documents we we nhsba
recommends that you pass those minutes
or documents off to your private council
because they're going to be able to
identify better what may be a privacy
issue what may be a confidentiality
issue aside from a layperson school
board member who you can recognize it
but you don't always necessarily know so
that's sort of the delay in the time and
the cost and getting some of those
redacted documents and reactive minutes
out thank you very much
barrett i have one question um
in looking at this type of bill right
here we're talking about comment periods
at various boards
how
widely an issue is that in this state
sure i know i've attended my board
and
we haven't had that problem
when i was on three terms in city
council we never had that problem right
um so what is the situation in the state
i i can read the papers i know there are
some places where there's been a lot of
acrimony
uh
but
what is it from your perspective as you
know working from the statewide new
hampshire school board association thank
you very much uh chairman ladd
um
the smaller the community the less of a
issue it tends to be i mean i've been at
some school board meetings where you do
get the dialogue and you do
just have the conversation those are
small communities a k through 5 k
through 6 district with maybe a couple
hundred kids and the school board
meetings representative porter mentioned
maybe 45 minutes long or an hour long so
you can have an extra half hour
you know what we saw
the the the and and and the frustration
shared by some members of the of this
committee yes i've heard those from
members of the public i've heard those
from school board members i'm not going
to dispute that
um you know but what we saw last summer
and fall that was not a public comment
issue let's be clear about that that was
denying people the right
or an opportunity to speak that was
people who had no interest in
in in abiding by any reasonable
regulations at school board meetings
when 150 people were showing up and
yelling and screaming and the chief of
police has to grab the chair and the
superintendent off the stage and shuttle
them back and put them in a locked
secure room until everybody goes home
that has nothing to do with a law public
comment or a school board policy
relative to public comments so
you know some districts had contentious
meetings i aware of one district i
believe senator carson said
her school board did not provide public
comments when this bill was first being
heard in in senate ed
former chair or a former school a former
school board member in londonderry and a
current school board member in
londonderry came to testify in support
of the bill and they talked about their
own experiences and i talked to them in
the hallway i said
why didn't your board adopt a public
comment policy then and i did so
you know
it
it's frustrating for some members of the
public and again i've heard the concerns
that have been shared by some members of
this committee
yes that's that that is what it is and
we're not trying to deny anybody an
opportunity to inform their their
elected officials of their concerns or
of their issues or complaints or
whatever it might be we're trying to
find
a system to manage how that can get done
while at the same time the board can
adopt policies adopt
review reports talk about the facilities
issue put its budget together you know a
typical school board meeting is probably
you know a
good efficient school board meeting for
just a medium-sized district it's
probably going to be two two and a half
hours
you know
do we have to make it four hours to
abide by this or to adhere to to a
public comment period i mean i if you
want to that that's fine and you know
some boards are more just more efficient
in general than other boards
so you know is it statewide
representative i would say no um you
know most of the um the issues that hit
the news and wmur last summer and fall
were in the southern part of the state
um you know kind of 95 up to i'd say
route 4 and over sort of that southeast
corner of the state from
nashua up to concord and then and then
over and there were some you know maybe
some other parts of the state but
the further north that you got i didn't
hear i we weren't getting calls or
concerns from
from from small districts up north
i don't know if that answers your
question yes you did
are there further questions of the
school boards association
yes
thank you and thank you
um if you could just please walk me
through this i think it would help so it
had been drilled into my head for years
when i joined the school board and and
they do kind of use you as a bible the
new hampshire school board association
and and in listening to
talk it's very different than what has
trickled down to me over the years and i
appreciate having this director right
now um
so that being said though i've been told
in the past that you're not required to
have public comment and then you know
the new hampshire school board
association is telling us this
um and then as representative hobson
mentioned that it is a meeting held in
public not a public meeting so when the
newer board members are being taught
that it is a meeting held in public not
a public meeting and you also do not
need to offer any type of public comment
i think it kind of sets the tone like
look
we're here in a huddle having a meeting
and
it's it's not your your business you can
listen and if you want
and i'm so i'm trying to under am i
understanding that correctly is it
i don't know no thanks for the question
representative just to be clear it's not
nhsba telling boards that they don't
have to have a public comment period
it's the law telling school boards they
don't have to have a public comment
period and then nhsba is advising boards
on what the law is um
i mean
to the question is it a public meeting
or is it a meeting of the public it's a
school board meeting
that has to be open to the public held
in public
so you know it's a business meeting of
the board that that's why we the board
has to meet to get its business done
whatever that business might be some
boards can do that efficiently with a
public comment period some boards
don't do that efficiently with or
without a public comment period
so
you know it it it's a business meeting
of the board held in public under the
right to no law i think it's the
clearest way to say it
it's you know we have there are other
types of
um
in the law
meetings that are more quote unquote of
the public
like your budget hearing anybody who
wants to come and speak you have to let
them come and speak you can't deny you
can limit it to three minutes per person
and reasonable regulations like that but
if you get a thousand people that want
to come and talk about your your budget
you have to let all thousands of those
people who registered to sign up to
speak have their three minutes
um bond hearings are this are the same
way you know when any any there's a
difference between a meeting and a
hearing for purposes of the law a
meeting under the right to know law is a
public body gathering to do its business
discuss its business deliberate vote in
public notice 24 hours minutes public
attend all that kind of stuff
then there's a public hearing this is a
hearing right now this is a
this me speaking about senate bill 410
is a public hearing
you can limit to two or three people as
you do on the big bills when you get a
thousand people but if a thousand people
want to come and talk about senate bill
410 and they all sign up you have to let
them speak so that's the difference
between a hearing in a meeting so does
that help
should i have told you that like seven
or eight years ago representative i
apologize
further questions
not seeing hands thank you very much if
there are any amendments and you can use
my assistance reach out at any time
thank you very much
state board of education
welcome drew thank you for the record
drew klein chairman of the state board
of education i'm neutral no position on
this bill i just came to give the
committee a little bit of um i don't
know background or just to help you
understand the state board situation and
what we're doing
um regarding public comment so the board
i inherited a public comment system
which was great and we kept it going um
barrett said there's always a
first amendment or a right to know
absolutist on every board and that's me
on our board and
um and rich salah our our newest board
member he's also that way
um and my view of this is
i have the entire the board has the
entire board meeting to speak
it's a business meeting as uh barrett
said
the value of having the public comment
section is uh
twofold one is to let
anybody who has some thoughts about what
might be on our agenda to let us know
and
and then you know to let us receive that
information like that informs our
thinking and our decision making and i
found it very useful i i think public
comment is extremely useful
and so what happened with the
with us was obviously march 2020 covet
hit um we switched to written public
comment
and that remained i was uh if there was
a
if that was not getting noticed on the
agendas that was an oversight we have
accepted written public comment since
march of 2020 and have said so in public
meeting multiple times
we intended to go back to public comment
at the beginning of this year the
coveted numbers were high
so we've been monitoring it to try to
decide when do we open back up to public
comment and the complication we have is
that we're not in our building anymore
so i don't know i mean i think most you
know department of ed is being
you know mitigated for um asbestos so
we're renting space in the granite state
college right now we don't control
that building
it is a key pad entry building
and they have very strict security at
the building
so
we've tried to work out with them and
we're still talking with them how would
uh the only reason we haven't gone back
to public comment yet and i'm planning
to do it next week at next week's
meeting
it's just logistical it's just trying to
figure out do we need to have a police
officer on the door we didn't have a
security do we need department of
education staff
to let people in um you know and then
once they're in the building this is a
college building
um we don't
operate it uh when we're in our own
building
you know we consider it
you know public building department of
ed people come in we've never had a
problem it's great but this isn't our
space so we just have to figure out
logistically how we're upstairs
so people have to come in one door all
the doors are keypad locked um so they'd
have to be shown which door to come in
we'd have to have somebody on the door
make sure they get upstairs to find our
meeting do we need two staffers you know
so anyway there's lots of
things logistical things to figure out
to make sure it works and it's okay with
granite state college our landlord and
making sure people don't get in and just
kind of wander around the building and
that kind of thing we have college
students there
so um so that's it it's just a
logistical issue that's the only reason
we haven't gone back at this point to
in-person public comment but we have
consistently
taken written public comment i can tell
you
um
this this bill is written in a way that
doesn't seem to take into account the
fact that the vast majority of public
comment these days is email
um
almost everything we get is on email uh
the percentage of emails we get versus
people showing up
um
there's a big discrepancy there i mean
you no longer
have to ride your horse to town meeting
and show up in person if you want to
you know tell your appointed elected
official what you think
you have direct access electronically to
them
through email so that's how we take most
of it i'm happy to get back to written
public or to in person public comment
want to do it
and then excited about doing it but in
writing a law
i would just suggest
there are unintended consequences um
and
the way things are worded should be very
considered very carefully and i'll give
you an example we
um
we have our public
uh input in the beginning of the meeting
always in the beginning
and
usually
typical that we may have three or four
people show up at most
most of our stuff is not
um controversial it's just rule writing
and so
we have public hearings we're required
to have a public hearing on the rules
and
so that's how the process works
unless it's something where
it's extremely controversial issue
and one side or the other usually it's
not two sides sometimes it is sometimes
one side will get very upset and they'll
get activists involved and then
they'll send people to come for the
public comment and i i think my first or
second meeting as board chair
our public comment period lasted two or
three hours we just let everybody speak
um and we've had several meetings like
that and we didn't get out until five or
six um and then that's you know just the
way it goes
um
and and and we don't
want to try to limit that
but i would just suggest that the way
this is worded and i think rep porter
made a good point
says public comment period shall be for
no less than 30 minutes
that should probably be clarified
to
let meetings start if nobody shows up or
if two people show up in the public
comment period and you don't have
anybody else there you don't want the
board to have to sit there twiddling
their thumbs in a public meeting
and doing nothing
while waiting for that clock to run out
so i think probably adding some language
i think representative cordelli
suggested that would be a good thing
if you're talking about
um
who should be allowed to speak if you
have people who are from out of
the community or not members not
residents
the wording in here
doesn't suggest that that would be
allowed it says provided such standards
are imposed equally for all speakers
so
i'm not sure that would be consistent
and then on the last point would be
comment versus exchange and
i view public comment as i said as an
opportunity for me to listen
that's the real value added um and if
somebody asks a question we're happy to
ask answer a question but if you word it
in such a way where you're
requiring or it comes across as you're
requiring the board to respond and
engage and ask questions
i get the intent
but i think that you could create
problems there i
i mean i've witnessed some meetings
where
public comment has happened and board
members have then taken it upon
themselves to correct
the what they perceive to be incorrect
statements of the public commenters
if you're encouraging that back and
forth that could be really good in terms
of getting answers but you could be
encouraging the board to engage in
discussion
that um
might not
actually help the people who just came
to comment express their views i mean i
think this is
again what we're talking about as a
hearing versus a business meeting and
these are these are business meetings
and you want to be able to connect your
business you want to be able to receive
that input but once you go
down the path of
making that a back and forth engagement
that can be productive but it can also
be very counterproductive so just be
careful about how you think about
wording that that's all
and that's all so thank you very much
are there any questions
drew i have uh one um
when i've been involved in various uh
meetings like this
uh and as a member of the either either
the council or a board
we've always had our policies and how we
conduct
our meetings based on either robert's
rules or based upon masons which we do
here in the house it's always been
robert's rules though and we as a board
have adopted
a process that's in place
my concern with all this is that
i
recognize the absolute need that people
have an opportunity to comment and voice
a position
i do have a problem with
on high
making decisions in regard to how to
operate and regulate and get down in the
weeds as far as writing 30 minutes or 40
minutes or this or that
does the state board of education have a
a policy or a format which they've
adopted on how they conduct school board
meetings or state board meetings i don't
think they're i didn't write one so
if tom raphael left me one uh i i don't
know where it is but my general i read
robert's rules of order years ago and
that's kind of how we follow it and i
don't know that there's anything that's
stated
to the public um that way but we
generally allow you know public comment
and welcome
welcome it and
you know if there's questions answered
we try to get those answered you know
through the right channels if we don't
know muffed up our heads but
it may be worthwhile i think it's
certainly worthwhile to always have a
written
statement um if there is one it predated
me
okay thank you all right representative
luno
thank you very much mr chair and thank
you very much chair klein um
i have to address both chairs uh right
here and and i i agree with with much of
what you um what you've just said and
and
i can certainly recognize you do have
very um you know long board meetings um
meetings of the state board can take all
day
and
and i think you're doing a good job to
efficiently manage those meetings to get
through that based on what
based on your testimony uh this
afternoon but
is it also your testimony and i just
want to make sure i get this right sure
that that um that your your current um
public comment um policy is as a result
of
restricted acts public access to um to
your board meetings
to to the building itself right so we
accept written public comment and have
but the the so the meetings are public
meetings and you know if you show up you
know we'll let you in
but
having a a public comment period was
something we thought was a little tricky
to manage but given the limited access
to the building
okay so so to be clear the the public is
not restricted to for in on
it's a public meeting if somebody
yeah if somebody shows up we will let
them in but when you when you have when
you announce a public comment period
um you potentially run into lots of
people showing up
and given that we don't own and control
the access to the building we're just
trying to figure out how to manage that
that's all okay thank you sure
i've been in that building many times
where would you go when you go into a
closed session or an executive session
where would the public go
the public can actually stay there we
it's a pretty decent space um we have a
um
we have seating that's kind of separated
from our our table so we could meet in
the same place and just close those
doors or we also have a conference room
another level up that we can access for
that thank you
okay any other questions
yeah representative moffatt
thank you mr thank you
ms cliff taking my question so um you
mentioned emails i hadn't some of us
maybe didn't give them a start to but
certainly here we get a lot of uh email
uh a lot uh which is public comment
especially to a listserv so my question
has to do with
a second hand or third person for
example earlier today
senator sherman was late and
representative luna
started off and introduced his bill on
his behalf
so in a public meeting um and i go back
to loudoun we had a town meeting and
there was a woman who came up to the
microphone and begged literally begged
permission to play a 30-second
electronic uh recording which the
moderator did not allow i think it made
everybody curious as to what was on
there but so my question to you is
uh for your purposes maybe you should
have asked this of mr christina as well
for public comment is it limited to
first person or can someone come and say
my uncle couldn't be here but i'm going
to read a statement from him
so yeah what about that um
i mean we've allowed people to read
statements from other people before i
don't
know that we've had somebody want to do
i think one time we might have had
somebody want to play a video i don't i
don't think we allowed that
um but we have a loud proxy testimony
like for that same reason somebody
wanted to be there and couldn't we
absolutely allowed that other you know
representative to give us
um comment for sure
yep
thank you
further questions
not seeing your hands thank you very
much
is there anybody else in the public
would like to speak on this bill
not seeing any this this uh bill is
closed
and that's
it for the day
uh we will not be of course exacting
anything today
and the next meeting we have is
scheduled for the 11th
that is uh next monday
where we will accept not exactly where
we will um address the remaining five
bills that this committee has received
and then there will be uh two days later
an exact session for the three bills
um that are early bills which have to be
out of this committee by the next day on
the 14th they have to be out we're even
getting to that deadline very quickly
here
there may be some other bills which we
have heard that we feel that we can exec
and we'll try and take care of them so
we can get some of these bills on the
agenda for the 21st
so we don't have to end up with all our
education bills on later on in the 28th
i've been told
that's right patty that that was the
last bill we got was on
friday was the last one we got we got an
early bill handed to us on friday
and so that just gave us this and then
we have to post it
and as soon as we could really get to it
would be
the 11th
and that gave us a couple days before we
had to have it out of committee not not
much time
well thank you very much everybody have
a a good rest of the week and enjoy the
weekend
you